Five,
four,
three,
two.
Oh,
what's happened?
Jamie went through Joseph.
How are you?
What's going on?
Doing good.
How you doing?
Good.
Welcome.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for coming on.
You.
You wrote an article and I tweet.
Let me tell you about my chiropractic
journey.
Um,
I had a podcast that I did with my
friend Steve Rinella a few weeks back at
Ya.
And he has a brother that has a
herniated disc real bad and he's got a
atrophy in one of his arms because he's
got a push nerve and you know,
the whole thing.
Bulging disc.
Not Good.
Yeah.
And uh,
we got to talk and I said,
look,
that guy's got to do something about it
right away because the more time you
spend with an atrophied arm,
the longer it takes to rehabilitate
that.
And it's a pretty common injury with
martial artists.
Get get yourself to a physical therapist
right away and get an Mri.
And then spinal decompression the whole
deal and see whatever science based.
Absolutely.
So he goes,
what do you think about chiropractors?
And I go,
so I say,
I think chiropractors are bullshit.
And then,
uh,
he goes,
really?
I go,
yeah,
I've just had bad experiences with it.
And then I've read some things about it
being bullshit.
And then I got home after the podcast
and I smoked a joint.
And a lot of times when I spoke to Paul
on,
I feel bad about some of the things that
I've said rarely do.
It's I,
I,
I smoked more than the average
scientist.
My boyfriend is a director of r and D at
a pot lab.
Oh,
there is some pot kicking around on a
regular basis while we get it free from
a bunch of people.
I have to tell people at shows and no
disrespect to people that offer to me.
I'm like,
please don't give me any pot.
I can't take your.
I have too much pot.
Wait,
we have a similar problem.
Um,
so anyway,
I smoke the pot and then I go,
God,
maybe I'm a dick.
Maybe that was rude saying because I
know people that are chiropractors and I
know they're nice people and I know they
mean well.
And I'm like,
maybe I'm a dick.
I think they mean,
well,
some of them,
sure,
I think they're wrong,
but they mean well,
so,
um,
I go maybe I was being a dick.
So then I Google chiropractic and then I
started reading and I spend hours and
hours reading about the history of cut.
I'm going to say this in big air quotes,
chiropractic medicine.
Go,
holy fucking shit.
Not only do I not feel bad now,
now I'm angry about it and this is to
all you people and I've got a ton of
messages from chiropractors that I'm
sure nice folks and they're really upset
because they liked this podcast and
they're like,
you know,
you're,
you're shitting on my business.
And you said you have to understand
it's,
I'm sure a lot of you are.
Meanwhile,
I'm sure a lot of you do.
Well,
I'm sure a lot of you try really hard to
help your patients and I'm sure a lot of
you incorporate a lot of other stuff
like massage,
cold laser and real science into your
therapies.
But the
origination,
the origin,
the original guy who created
chiropractic medicine was a complete
total bullshit artists fucking whack
just guy right here.
This,
this character Daniel,
David Palmer.
So it started as a magnetic healer in
Davenport,
Iowa.
I mean the whole thing is hundred
percent horseshit.
This article that we wrote,
we sent this through A.
I mean,
normally my articles I go through at
least two editors,
give or take this one,
we put through,
I believe three editors,
a fact checker and our lawyer to make
sure that we were bulletproof on it
because we wanted to make sure that we
know that,
that we didn't say anything that could
get sued basically in a lot of the
information from this came directly from
his book,
from his own book.
So we weren't taking anything out of
context.
One of the quotes on how chiropractic
started came directly from the book and
he after,
um,
after cracking a,
a half deaf persons or a deaf person's
telling Jamie just had pulled up in that
article,
pull it back up,
Jamie.
So you could see that he claimed that he
cracked a deaf person's back.
And restorative healing or his hearing
now,
a couple of things could have happened
here.
Either one,
there was no actual medical consent
given because this person was def.
Uh,
so I'm not sure how,
uh,
how that came about too.
He didn't actually restore the hearing
because there are no nerves in the spine
connected to your hearing.
Uh,
or you know,
three,
this guy is just lying.
There are a couple,
you know,
and we're not sure what happened,
but he,
like,
there are still in Chiropractic,
could have done a few things with this.
They could have disavowed what happened
and said,
you know,
we still have a system by which we can
really try to relieve pain through
spinal manipulation.
But no,
there are still articles out today from
chiropractors today that try to claim
that yes indeed he did restore hearing
because I was like,
no.
Could you guys just maybe back down on
some of the nuttier claims because
there,
there is some,
some minor evidence that you can relieve
back pain,
lower back pain with spinal
manipulation.
And there are,
there are a Kairos that are trying to be
science based with this,
but the history of it is so ridiculous
and they try to back down on nothing and
that's not how science works.
Science works with the newest evidence
and it tries to figure out what's real
and what's not and they try to double
down on all the craziest stuff and I
think there are Kairos that are trying
to fix the field maybe and say,
you know,
spinal manipulation can help with back
pain,
but that's not what this claims.
It claims that you can fix everything in
the body through these vertebral
subluxations that have never been shown
what is a subluxation?
So there are a couple,
there's,
there are two terms being used here and
chiropractic uses it incorrectly.
And in medicine we use it correctly.
So a subluxation,
the actual medical term means that a
joint pops out halfway.
So you have a dislocation was which is a
complete separation of a joint
basically.
And a subluxation is a partial
dislocation.
I know because they happened to my
shoulder there.
There are a fun party trick.
I'll spare you a but of subluxation in
the chiropractic sense.
They use this medical term kind of
incorrectly.
They say that your spine can be somewhat
out of joint basically,
and it causes all your health problems,
like your pancreas is malfunctioning
because your spine is out of alignment
and it's never been proven to happen and
they claim that they can put you into a
state of health by massaging your back
and it.
Here's what's important about this.
This was created out of thin air by a
guy who was a quack.
The origin is not based on years and
years of medical research.
None of this.
All of this came from the 18 hundreds
from a guy who was completely full of
shit and he was.
He was a magnetic healer.
Now,
magnetic healing,
you can still see at the store these
little like knee braces that have
magnets and a guys save your money.
Just get a regular old knee brace.
If you feel any,
any relief from one of those magnetic
braces.
It's just from the brace.
It's not the fucking magnet.
Yeah,
exactly.
Placebo effects or the placebo effect is
a real thing.
You can get some relief from that,
but don't bother,
which may also account for some of the
pain relief from chiropractic medicine.
Absolutely.
I mean they're doing exactly like
they're doing some massage along with
what they're doing and some of them
problem because massage actually helps
and there there are studies that show
people who go to a massage therapist or
massage practitioner tend to get more
relief than people who go to a,
to a chiropractor.
So please go to a massage therapist,
go to a,
uh,
to a physical therapist.
Those are,
those are your science based
practitioners.
Chiropractic.
It started out of bullshit and it's
stayed directly in bullshit.
Like there's no reason that anybody
would have from this guy,
from this one original guy who created
it.
This guy was a magnetic healer who came
up with this somehow or another,
it's slipped through the cracks and
that's what this is.
I mean,
they're running around calling
themselves.
Doctors say,
this guy said to me,
one of these guys who got angry at me,
I've,
I've gotten at least two dozen maybe
angry messages for rafters,
but one of them,
the guy said,
does a podiatrist go to medical school?
Well,
the fuck they go to podiatry school.
Not only that,
they take,
they have a medical residency that they
have to do for three years.
They,
they,
they actually go to a hospital to work
in the hospital and the podiatry is like
an actual science of studying this foot
and some of them are.
I could be wrong on this.
Someone go ahead and please fact check
me.
I believe some of them are pediatric
surgeons,
like they have to know all the anatomy
of the feet in order to treat actual
foot conditions.
They are like,
these are part of the medical system.
Ca chiropractic works kind of separately
and on theories that uh,
that have never been proven to work.
They can't even do imaging like half.
I believe something like half of
chiropractic clinics don't even have x
rays.
So how can they show you 100 percent for
sure that what they're claiming is
happening in your back isn't happening.
And I read,
I mean,
these are statistics that I found
straight from chiropractic websites,
from their organizations.
Um,
and I,
I had this referenced in the article,
I just am blanking on which place had
this,
one of the chiropractic boards that does
large scale surveys within Chiropractic,
uh,
about half.
There were a lot of places,
a lot of people I'm sure said to you,
but my chiropractor's good microfracture
doesn't do the bullshit stuff and a lot
of my friends said that too.
They said no,
they just crack my back.
They don't try to sell me any bullshit
supplements.
About half of chiropractors do the
bullshit stuff.
They do the extra,
the extraneous wellness stuff.
So when,
if you have a 50,
if you're playing Russian roulette and
you have a 50 percent chance of getting
a bullshit,
uh,
or,
or getting a bullet,
are you going to do that?
No.
Like that's,
I don't want a 50 percent chance of
having a bullshit Dr who's like,
well,
maybe your colds really a German,
you know,
maybe it's a bowl.
I don't want the bullshit doctor.
I want the guy who knows what he's
talking about and this is what you're
getting with chiropractic.
You're getting a bullshit doctor and
it's even if you're not a doctor.
Yeah,
exactly.
Part of the problem they call themselves
doctor,
have you seen that's so fucked up,
checking in on this.
They don't go to medical school.
It's,
they go to,
they go to chiropractic school is now
one of the biggest chiropractice schools
in the country is a Palmer chiropractic
college and that's named for DD Palmer.
The guy who launched,
launched this bevy of bullshit on us and
he a guy named after the guy who claimed
it heal up and it's one of one of my.
Now this is crazy.
So we're going to be a fun story.
By Fun,
I mean horrifying.
One of the guys I went to Undergrad with
a went to Palmer chiropractic college.
Now the acceptance rate,
100 percent tuition,
$34,000 a year to learn how to crack
babies,
spines.
Now the guy I went to college,
but some people do,
some of them do know it is a growing
field and chiropractic.
This one guy said this hilarious.
He said,
you're saying the crack babies bonds.
It's a gentleman emulation.
Like why?
Yeah,
exactly the thing.
Why?
Why the fuck are you manipulating?
Because there's no evidence whatsoever
that helps babies.
The babies aren't complaining about back
pain.
Yeah,
no.
Here's,
here are the two things that I've heard.
One is,
uh,
is that it's so gentle.
It wouldn't even bruise a tomato skin.
Then why are you doing it?
Why now?
The other thing they say it's bullshit
because they can pay.
They can charge parents.
That's why the other thing they say is,
well,
from doing that,
you,
because,
and this is this,
this infuriates me so much.
Um,
they say from manipulating the spine,
because the spine has,
within those bones,
they had the spinal column and the
nerves control everything in the body.
And so from,
from stimulate,
stimulating the nerves,
you can give the infant all the immunity
it needs to not need their vaccinations.
And that's when I get really.
Oh yeah,
they claimed this shit there.
You got to be real specific claiming
that by manipulating a baby,
they don't need vaccines.
This is no,
this is,
I understand.
This is not all chiropractors,
but the American chiropractic
association.
This is fairly well cited within the
article,
the American Chiropractic Association,
they are generally anti-drug.
They want to use the least amount of
inter inter medical interventions
possible.
And chiropractors are not in most states
in this country.
They are not cleared to either prescribe
or give vaccinations.
So if you can manage to get a family to
come into you for pretty much all of
their medical needs,
that increases your bottom line and it
stops,
you know,
and,
and you're going to say,
we can do everything for you.
Of course,
the chiropractors and cleared for
vaccination.
Of course they don't.
They don't give vaccinations.
And I mean one of.
There's one state in this country,
I believe it was Wisconsin,
where they were trying to get
chiropractors to be able to give pre
sports physicals and in in some cases
the pre sports physical is the only time
all year when a student will see a
doctor.
So this is,
this is infuriating.
So the like whenever a doctor and I mean
this is like you can look at the acs
website,
there is a put a couple of links to it
in the article where they say,
you know,
they're,
they're not very provax and I mean their
language on it is under the condition of
freedom of choice,
medical choice.
And it's like they don't say straight
out vaccines don't work.
They're bad for you,
but they're kind of,
they're wishy washy on it and they're
not.
They don't say vaccines work and you
should get them,
but a couple of chiropractors will try
to say we don't need vaccines.
We can increase your immune system.
We can increase your immunity by
pressing zero evidence,
zero evidence.
And I'm like,
do me a favor,
tell me which spine,
which part of the spine you press on to
give child immunity to measles and
polio.
Give me,
tell me.
Give me the titers.
Test that child's titers to show me that
they're immune to polio.
Now from you touching their goddamn
spine.
Maybe I.
It's like,
how about this?
How about I'll punch you in the.
I'm not going to punch a chiropractor.
How about I just,
you know,
not just give you a few little,
like a little pokes in the back and then
you're going to be immune to smallpox.
Just just let me know how that works.
But I can't.
I can't get behind a system that has no
evidence and tells me it's going to make
children immune to deadly diseases.
Here's a real question.
How did it get this far?
Like how,
how did this guy who's a magnetic healer
who had no background in medicine come
up with this system and then have it
spread all over the world?
It's such a good story,
isn't that people love a story that says
that you can heal them without,
uh,
without taking dangerous drugs and at
the time and forget about medicine
wasn't even just just helping you with
anything.
It's really,
it's partially because of when it came
up because we only found out 50 years
after this that uh,
that uh,
frontal lobotomies were a bad fucking
idea and that the little was going to
kill babies.
Uh,
so we were,
we were really fucking bad at medicine
when this came up and we're,
I mean,
we're way better at it now,
but we still don't have the answers to
everything.
And that's kind of,
I don't want to say a failure of the
medical system,
but it's just a sign of where we are
now.
So think about the number of people who
have sent us anecdotes saying,
you know,
I was in miserable pain and my
chiropractor was the only thing that
worked.
And it's like maybe you needed to get a,
you know,
get to physical therapy for longer term
pain.
But these people that are still going to
their Kairos,
it means they're still in pain and they
should go to a physical therapist for,
you know,
a couple months of therapy that will
eventually strengthened their backs and
take care of those issues and you know,
get a massage,
but they're going to their Cairo because
medical has not said,
you know,
we don't have a tricorder that can scan
you,
show the exact thing and say here's the
exact medicine drug and thing that will
fix you.
It's kind of,
and I hate to use this term,
but it's out of the failures of the
medical system that something like this
has shown up,
so we're not perfect at medicine yet.
And that's why alternative medicine
swoops in with bullshit.
It's just a matter of innovation.
It's like there's a certain level that
the medical community is at right now.
It's pretty staggering what they're
capable of,
but it's still growing and learning and
we're in a constant state of progress.
But what's shocking to me is how far
this medical healer or magnetic healers
quack idea.
God.
I just thought it was based on
something.
I mean,
I really did.
I've been going to a chiropractor for
years or different chiropractors for
years.
It's in.
One of them was like this guy used to go
to on Hollywood is 40 bucks.
It's literally he would take care of you
for like 10 minutes.
He would rub your back a little bit and
massage a little bit and then he would
pop it and then go,
oh,
we got it.
We got it.
And I'd be like,
okay.
And I would think her head,
man,
maybe I'll start feeling better now.
I've got a foam roller for 20 bucks that
I can lend.
Jill will crack your back really well.
So.
Well,
yeah.
Um,
it's just,
it's just stunning to me that insurance
companies pay for it and that it's been
around so long.
How did that happen?
How are insurance companies?
There was some lobbying,
and I don't think I put this into the
article,
but there was a lot of lobbying from
chiropractors in I believe the seventies
that pushed the American Medical
Association and uh,
and the insurance companies as a whole
to kind of accept them as being
medically a part of the system.
And that's part of why more and more
insurance companies now will cover them
and accept them.
And even though like most doctors won't,
like a lot of doctors won't refer you.
They'll kind of be like,
well,
you can look into Cairo.
Like there's still from a lot of doctors
push back,
uh,
but there's a little bit more coverage
now just because of a lot of lobbying in
the seventies
now have chiropractors do have a center
or a treatment center or whatever it is.
And they have a bunch of different
methods that they employ.
This is not saying that those other
methods might not give you some relief,
but the actual cracking of the next and
the cracking of the back,
there's virtually no evidence at that
heals anything.
Or he stops and he promotes your immune
system functioning better or anything
like that on all these things that it's
based on.
It's precisely like the big thing is
that,
I mean there,
if they were just claiming we can reduce
your back pain,
if that was the only thing they claimed,
I wouldn't have written the article,
you know,
but what they're claiming is that they
can fix all of your health by realigning
these vertebral subluxations which have
never been proven to exist.
So like what are you doing when you're
back pops?
What is actually happening?
It's like,
I wish I had intergen being released or
something.
I think it's just moving around air
bubbles like enemy in tiny little bits
of bubbles and yeah,
they are like,
they're,
I don't think realigning is the right
word,
but you know,
they're,
they're doing their,
they're moving around your back in a way
that it kind of national news because
you can kind of move and twist in your
back will pop.
But like,
they're doing some manipulation of
things that kind of naturally happened
to,
uh,
to a spine,
with,
you know,
with a tiny little bit tiny bit of
degeneration with age,
I think I'm not exactly the right expert
to explain this type of thing.
An osteopath would be a better person to
explain this because there's a,
there are people who are a little better
at spinal manipulation than a
chiropractor,
which is a dio and osteopaths.
So in this country we have mds and dos
and they both can practice medicine,
doctor of osteopathy,
a doctor of osteopathy.
I believe that's the correct term.
And my doctor is actually,
uh,
my,
primary care is an osteopath and he's
given me a spinal manipulation once,
when my back was killing me and we had
no idea what it was.
And it turned out I had a broken rib,
which was not a good time to do a spinal
manipulation.
We've got a rib broken right on your
spine,
but it was like he,
um,
the difference is an osteopath never
claimed that they're,
um,
they're cracking your back to try it.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're,
they're giving you,
they're giving you your vaccines,
they're doing,
you know,
they're going,
wow,
there's something wrong with your,
with your,
uh,
a we're going to send you to a
gynecologist.
Like they're,
they're doing all the things that
doctors should do for your health and if
your back is in pain,
they'll say,
do you want to try and make a
manipulation?
They're not pushing that,
that's a part of their care.
And they try to do science based,
uh,
you know,
manipulations for the potential help of,
uh,
of a back relief,
but they don't know.
They don't want to do that longterm.
They do it minimally.
At least that's been my experience with
it.
And it seems to be like,
There still seems to be,
I'd say at best weak evidence that it
helps with,
uh,
with back pain.
Well,
the problem is they usually do it with
other things that also has been shown to
help with back pain.
So like,
like I said,
and also just breast.
Yes.
Breast ice,
antiinflammatories seeing all these
different factors.
And while I went to a chiropractor and
he helped me.
Yeah.
And I make,
I think that,
I think it's funny the things that
chiropractors add into it because like
one of the things that I went into in
this,
uh,
in this article because we,
we,
we really like diving deep on some of
the things that we investigate.
Um,
and it's like I try,
I,
like,
I'll admit I'm biased when I go in,
I,
because I,
I go after a lot of kind of,
some of the naturally things and I'm
not,
I'm not anti natural.
Like I,
I'm not 100 percent against going into
homeopathics.
It's funny because we can,
we can go into some of it's real,
right?
Like garlic really is good for
infections or some stuff that's
legitimate.
Good for your heart.
Ginger,
I love when I have a stomach ache,
I'll go for ginger before I go first.
Remedies that work.
There are some herbal remedies and I'm
like,
absolutely.
Keep them in your,
in your cabinet.
I'm not against them,
but I'm against people taking things
without evidence.
And I think that's the thing.
Like try,
try absolutely it to look for the hard
evidence,
uh,
before you waste your money.
And I think that's the thing that people
have fallen into because they'll say,
oh,
it's natural,
it's better.
It's like,
because polio is natural,
I don't think it's very good for you,
like,
but I,
I know,
I know that's a straw man,
fully aware of it.
But I also think that people should,
should ask for evidence and you never
know,
asked for it to manned it before you
give somebody your money and that's what
people haven't done with chiropractors.
And that is the very good point.
And it's,
you know,
I think people deserve evidence and
that's.
And I think that's something that hasn't
been out in the public sphere.
Like there was an article I was trying
to write a while ago,
um,
I forget the exact topic,
but one of my editors,
uh,
you know,
sending it back to me credit,
she's like,
I've read that she,
uh,
her comment back was,
well,
I've been reading this a lot online.
A lot of people have been saying this.
I'm like,
a lot of people have been saying is not
evidence.
That's the exact opposite of it.
Like I'm like,
here,
I put in the peer review data on this
yet or I didn't work with her again.
She was.
A lot of people have been saying,
you can't do that.
That's not.
That's the end.
I mean this is why I liked the editor,
so I'm working with now quite a bit.
The problem with this whole clinic thing
though is that they don't have to have
any sort of background in kinesiology or
in physical therapy or any of these
things and so they incorporate all these
other modalities,
all these other methods of healing you,
but they don't have to have a background
in education in those things and they're
calling themselves a doctor.
No,
there is.
There is one thing I've heard of,
and this isn't.
This is why I'd say don't go to a
chiropractor because we don't know.
You don't know what you're going to walk
into,
but I have heard a couple of cases of
times this being the case where a
chiropractor at first they go to school
for physical therapy and then they find
they can't open their own clinic.
Even if they've got like an MBA and a
physical therapy background.
They're like,
how do I open my own clinic?
And they realize if they just go to
school for Chiropractic,
they can do the physical therapy work
they want to and offer a spinal
manipulation on the side.
Now how long does it take to get a
degree in Chiropractic?
Forty three,
three,
four years.
Like it's.
I mean it's a lot of school,
but think about a learn.
I had a,
had a crack spines.
I mean the thing that I think created by
a guy who's a quack,
what the fuck could they possibly be
teaching you for four years?
I do.
They do learn some anatomy,
but it's like they also learned some
bullshit along with it.
So I'm like,
I wonder.
And I mean this isn't.
I get it.
This isn't all chiropractor's obviously,
but like I know it's hard to figure out
which one you're going to walk into
that's going to be a bullshit artist and
not so like I,
I did want it like this isn't,
this wasn't the point I was going to
bring up in an article that was going to
have a specific point of view,
but like I know there are some out there
that say I,
you know,
I to give people physical therapy,
I want to strengthen up their spine,
I want to get them out of here in less
pain so that if they injure themselves
again,
they know they can come back to me and
trust me with their spine and also give
them some relief while we're fixing
them.
So,
you know,
this is a thing that happens,
but I don't think it's all the time.
It's,
I mean he's clearly not all the time.
So you know,
you're going to have some really moral
people in every field and you're gonna
have some really fucked up once in every
field.
Like we were.
One of the things we touched on in the
article were these very social media
savvy people,
and this is something that drives me
fucking crazy.
You have to hunt and peck through their
websites to find that they say that
they're a chiropractor.
They just say doctor everywhere Dr,
and they're giving.
They're giving recipe ideas and they're
giving and they're talking about the
adrenal glands and the adrenal glands.
They're not anywhere near close to the
spine and this is the thing that they're
talking about.
I'm like,
the adrenal glands are,
they're part of talking about
manipulating the spine to help the
adrenal glands.
They're talking about.
One of the things they talk about a lot
is adrenal fatigue syndrome,
which has never been proven to be a
thing.
It's not recognized as a,
as a disorder anywhere within the
medical care system.
Now you can have a couple of different
disorders of the adrenal gland.
You have cushing's syndrome.
Um,
have like,
there are a couple of different things
that can go wrong with.
Your adrenal glands are a little glands
that sit on top of the kidneys.
Uh,
but this is the specialty I believe.
Hold on a second,
having a blonde moment on the words,
uh,
but like there's the,
a sub specialty,
but the specialty for which you're going
to study the adrenal glands isn't even a
specialty that chiropractic has.
So it's like if you want to know about
your,
if you're having issues with that,
like it's like the,
the things that chiropractor seem to
harp on right now,
or a lot with,
uh,
immunology or a lot with,
sorry,
just having a complete blonde moment on
this.
Uh,
but there,
there are specialties at chiropractor
seem to harp on a lot lately and it
seems to be the types of things that are
very nebulous and very hard to,
uh,
to nail down when someone's having an
issue with it.
And these are,
these are things that chiropractors just
don't have the training in.
So essentially someone's putting up a
health website and they're claiming to
be a doctor and they're offering all of
this advice on diet and all these
different things.
But when you get to what is their degree
in,
they don't.
It's not a real doctor.
It's a chiropractor and it's,
and they're basically all,
they're the type of advice they're
giving is take all these herbs,
eat a,
you know,
eating an alkaline diet,
which is again,
bullshit.
Um,
it's,
there's one of my favorite things with
the alkaline diet is they're always
like,
drink lemon water.
I'm like,
that's acidic,
which I might know from my chemistry
degree,
you know,
what is the premise of this alkaline
diet?
Because I remember people were pushing
that awhile back saying that you could
cure cancer and shit just by having a
diet that's alkaline sort of acidic it,
which is,
I mean like,
and that's the premise of it.
And,
but it's like they,
here's the thing,
we are,
your body's Ph is really tightly
controlled.
Like your blood is between,
I think seven point three,
five and seven point five,
five.
A different organ systems have a fairly
tightly controlled ph of your urine can
vary a little bit depending on what
you've consumed.
But there's,
you know,
there's a tightly controlled Ph within
your body.
If you're suddenly go,
you know,
if suddenly you have a Ph of 10,
which is,
you know,
fairly alkaline,
your,
they're,
your friends are your friends are going
to miss you at your funeral,
hopefully.
Um,
so that's,
that's what I got on that.
But like she didn't have a high ph.
you're dead if you're suddenly because
you know that's a,
that's an alkaline ph.
if you're suddenly really,
really alkaline,
we're gonna miss you.
That's someone to be that alcohol,
drinking a bunch of lie.
I don't know,
like,
don't do you.
I mean you're like,
there's something really wrong with your
ability to filter things out of your
body if you're suddenly like,
that's just,
it's just not a thing that happens to a
healthy human.
If you're all of a sudden really
alkaline,
but this diet won't do it.
Especially when the things that they're
recommending are like lemons,
like,
and one of the things they say is,
oh,
well your body takes that acidic fruit
and turned it alkaline.
I'm like,
go to the,
where are they coming up with this
stuff?
This is just nonsense that someone's
just repeating online and there.
Oh,
and the things I say like the,
the Diet they've designed is a fairly
low calorie diet.
Like it'll make you lose weight,
but it's not going to make you go
alkaline and it's not going to fucking
fight cancer.
Like it's,
if anything,
the reduction in calories or probably be
good because you lose some body fat.
We have less inflammation
like,
yeah,
it's,
there are,
there have been shown to be,
you know,
links between lower,
uh,
lower body fat and lower incidences of
cancer,
which is,
you know,
that's a good thing.
Losing weight if you're,
if you're overweight and you're having
medical problems from it overall good
thing.
But there is no,
uh,
shown a link between,
between this specific diet and a lower
incidence of cancer or any other
disorders.
But it's just like
so fat.
It's just one of those things.
I remember when people were wearing
those,
uh,
holograms attached to a rubber band
around their wrist.
And do you remember these stupid fucking
things?
Do you remember him?
Jamie?
You remember him,
right?
Gwyneth paltrow has gotten trouble for
selling them on her like fucking bitch.
No offense squared,
but I might've.
I might've said some mean things about
Glenn.
Have been a couple of things about her
lately.
Inner fucking nutty website she takes.
You're supposed to wear like a rock
inside your vagina is not one of those
things.
I call them pussy rocks.
That's rocks are hilarious.
I guess it would be like strengthen you
if you want to strengthen it.
Just two key goals around a dick.
That's my.
That's my method.
Works for Cambrian rocks.
A good way to go.
Gwyneth paltrow wants to heal you with
magic stickers.
Jesus Christ bitches.
She needs getting paid.
They'll tell you that.
There's a lot of dummies out there that
are sought all the way is atm machine.
She is proof that sells way better than
science.
I'm.
I do not have her.
Her salary.
Well wait a minute.
Could rebalance the energy frequency.
I didn't know that.
Hold on a second.
She's discovered something about
stickers different.
Take these stickers.
If they're made with the right material,
you just stick them on your body in the
right places.
And they,
in quotes,
rebalanced,
the energy frequency in our bodies are
made out of a NASA space suit material.
And NASA said it was a load of bs.
But hold on a second.
I don't think that NASA is right.
Bunch of movies,
iron man science.
It says Gwyneth paltrow's goop website,
a lifestyle business lifestyle which
sells all things.
Gwyneth advertise.
These stickers are using NASA space suit
material,
which presumably was the source of their
magic healing properties.
Jesus fucking Christ,
she's special stickers have not made.
This is what NASA says.
They're not made of space suit material,
not that space.
New suit material that has healing
properties in the first place.
It doesn't,
but the quote from the foreign NASA
scientist,
Mark Shoal,
Shell Shell,
Shell Hummer,
Shelmar Shalimar sums it up.
He goes,
wow,
what a load of bs this is or that.
Yeah,
okay.
She's obviously goop.
Quickly updated its site.
Now it doesn't claim anything about NASA
space suits and stickers,
but it didn't dial back in in the
magical healing claims.
Here's what groups has now in an article
called wearable stickers that promote
healing in parentheses.
Really?
You fuck human bodies operate at an
ideal energetic frequency,
but everyday stresses and anxiety.
You give me stress,
you bitch.
You can throw off our internal balance,
depleting our energy reserves and
weakening our immune system.
I'm fucking imagine thinking that you
could put a sticker on you and it's
going to heal you.
Body vibe stickers.
Oh my God.
They're called body vibes coming.
Pre-Pro.
They come preprogrammed.
Oh,
fuck.
The programming.
I didn't know that.
To an ideal frequency,
allowing them to target imbalances.
You motherfucker,
you fucking crook.
Don't you have enough money,
bitch.
Jesus Christ.
The residuals on the iron man movies
just weren't enough for her.
God Damn.
60 bucks for a 10 pack.
Hold Shit.
10 stickers for 60 bucks.
Oh my God.
I'm in the wrong industry.
Apparently.
I need to start selling some fancy
motherfucking stickers.
No,
you don't.
no,
but look,
this is a very.
This is a very controversial subject,
right?
Like anything that's not regulated by
the FDA,
like I,
I'm a part of a in interest of full
disclosure,
part of the company on it,
which is a,
we sell supplements,
but the supplements that we sell,
we,
we control everything that we sell,
so we make sure that we do testing on
it.
The supplements that we sell,
like this shit.
A Alpha brain did do d,
Two double blind placebo controlled
studies at Boston Center for memory that
showed increase in verbal memory
increase in.
Um,
there's a bunch of different things.
What was the other one?
Um,
there was a reaction time,
but there's a whole,
there's actual scientific studies on
nootropics.
They've been around for a long time.
The nutrients about them just because
like I've,
I haven't looked into them enough and
I'm,
I know they're kind of their new ish,
you know,
into the supplement market.
So like I kind of want to look into them
and I don't know enough to comment.
Essentially the building blocks for
human neurotransmitters,
which your body uses,
the nutrients your body uses to make
human neurotransmitters.
There's nothing woo woo about it.
Nothing crazy.
It's all backed by science,
but when we started putting them out,
there was a lot of people that were
claiming bullshit.
You're selling snake oil,
so we had a control these studies and we
had to pay for them at the Boston Center
for memory and put.
We also had to make sure that we put a
full 100 percent money back guarantee on
any of the supplements where you don't
have to return them.
Just say they didn't work for you.
Will you will try and make it as clean
as possible.
This is stuff that I use,
I find benefit in it.
Let's see what people think about it and
let's make sure that we have studies,
but when you sell things like stickers,
like there's no fucking studies on
stickers.
Said like when she was on a camel a few
weeks ago and he was like,
so how does it work?
Eventually just came out and said,
I don't know how any of this shit works.
It's like,
yeah,
because you're selling rocks for your
pulse.
Does she have somebody else?
It doesn't make me and they're just
unscrupulous and she's a part of it.
She's a CEO and she's apparently in all
the meetings when she just busy reading.
It's reading scripts and shit.
Look at this one.
Look at this.
Oh,
antianxiety unicorn skin at the beach.
Beauty,
sleep.
Wait a minute.
One of each vibe.
One of the vibes of the beach.
Chill.
That's what the preprogrammed chilled
for.
For self love.
One of them is chilled for UNICORNS.
Skin.
That's a real love.
I demand an orgasm within three minutes.
I don't think it works that way.
Right?
All.
Yeah.
I don't just feeling good about
yourself.
It doesn't Gaillard rock rocked out,
but these things are like,
you know,
it's really weird.
It's like I'm not a big fan of the
government stepping in and you know,
regulating everything because I know
there's a lot of supplements that
actually do work and for them to be,
to get passed by the FDA,
you have to go through these exhaustive
tests.
They cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
It's a huge thing.
It takes a long time and I mean,
here's the.
I think that like the reason why I'm a
fan,
I have at least some amount of
government regulation on supplements is
to stop,
unscrew a very unscrupulous claims
because especially with some of the
supplement industry,
they,
there are claims that these are,
um,
that there are certain things on or
sorry in a package and after,
you know,
some independent testing,
you'll find that some of the,
uh,
some packages don't have what they claim
in their,
like some,
it was something like a third of a
supplement packages didn't have any of
the ingredients in there or they had
less of it.
And I'm like that's not,
that's not good for the consumer.
So I wish there was a way to regulate it
a little bit better.
At least
I just don't think it should be the
government.
I think there should be like some sort
of an independent company that works in
a very scientific way where you know,
you can hire them to test your stuff and
run these tests where you can show
there's gotta be some way to show that
there's no collusion and there's no
bribery that everything's above board.
But I dunno what the fuck that would be.
I don't know how that would be.
I'm not sure how it would work.
I mean it's like I know the FDA has
issues.
I know that drug approval definitely has
Like there have been drugs that have
been passed that have had issues,
but
the fentanyl,
that's all you need to know.
They saw oxycontin and fentanyl and
people are prescribing shit that takes
forever for people to get off a massive
addiction rates.
Things like fentanyl have some,
some very limited purpose.
Just like I've been put on fentanyl for
a pre surgery before.
Just,
you know,
they put you on it just to put you out.
Let's get this check.
Highs.
I remember about 30 seconds and I was
told I threw up a while.
It was under.
Um,
and I don't remember.
Yeah.
Now I know that I can't have fentanyl,
but it's,
that was,
they just put you on to put you out.
But that's like,
that's one of very few ethical
applications of,
of fentanyl.
And I mean,
it depends on,
like I did my master's thesis on
prescription opioid abuse trends and
toxicology.
So this is,
this is a spirit that I know pretty
well,
uh,
but this is a,
that's kind of one of the things with
painkillers is that there's,
there are ethical prescribing practice
with their ethical ways to manage a
patient use of it and then they're
really horribly unethical ways that it
can be prescribed and managed over time.
And this is something that the FDA
hasn't managed well.
This is something that a lot of doctors
haven't managed well and it's like we,
I mean we started this when we were,
when they were like let's go on a
marketing campaign.
Bureaucracy gone down and it just kept
getting worse from there.
It was like there's,
there has to be a better way to manage
what we're doing right now with it and
it's not being done yet.
So obviously this has nothing to do with
Gwyneth paltrow goop,
but I just think that they're some sort
of an independent company or some sort
of.
I mean,
naughty,
I keep saying business,
but there's so many problems with doing
that and there's also problems with
having the government do it.
I just don't think they'd been adequate
so far and the FDA stepping in and
regulating all vitamins and,
and making,
you know,
they wanted to do that for a while.
They wanted to call them nutraceuticals.
They wanted to,
um,
to have prescriptions for vitamins and
things along those lines.
But the problem with that is I don't
want to have to go to the doctor to get
multivitamins,
but I do want to make sure that the
multivitamins that I get are pure or
safe,
not just safe,
but that what you're asking for,
are you looking for be 12?
I want to make sure I'm getting be 12.
The other question is how much of a
vitamin D you need and I think that buy
vitamins indiscriminately because we
really don't like the average person
doesn't need to take a multivitamin in
the day if they're eating,
you know,
a healthy diet because you get pretty
much what you need on a daily basis.
If you're not somebody with an
absorption issue,
if you're not somebody with a,
any like any dietary issues,
you're generally getting what you need
out of your diet.
Um,
I think people do need to.
If your diet is really healthy,
it's.
But most people do not have a really
healthy diet.
Most people are getting about what they
need out of their diet.
Most people seriously,
it's,
I mean if we have some of the poorest
people are just eating processed
bullshit.
Well No,
it's even if you go to the doctor and
get an average person,
I'm guessing you eat fairly healthy,
but the average person that they go to
the doctor to see if they're deficient
on everything,
on anything,
they're not going to be deficient.
I've gone and gotten my blood work done
several times.
Deficiencies and deficiencies in Vitamin
D.
No,
I,
I've been before.
But that was right when I was diagnosed
with CELIAC disease.
So I was,
I was deficient at a few things.
But you know,
that's,
that's an issue with wheat and you have
an issue absorbing food.
Yeah.
So I mean now it will.
Now that I've been,
it's,
it was,
I was at the skinniest point in my life
and then I stopped eating wheat and I
gained weight.
So because suddenly you're,
you're kind of,
you know,
they,
they heal and you're able to absorb
calories.
Again.
I have a friend who's got a son who they
was trying to figure out why he was so
small.
He just,
he couldn't eat and he was never hungry
and he was eating,
you might get sick here.
Everything is miserable and he's got a
wheat allergy.
He's got a corn allergy.
Jesus,
everything was just making him
miserable.
I mean,
I got quote unquote lucky.
I only got symptoms when I was in
adults.
Uh,
and it was,
you know,
you ate wheat all throughout your
childhood years.
No problem,
no problem.
And I mean I was even overweight as,
as a kid.
So then when I was an adult,
suddenly horrible symptoms showed up.
It just doesn't work.
What do they have an idea of a celiac
can show up,
are the symptoms of.
It can,
like you always have the underlying
physiology or um,
and just all of a sudden symptoms can
just show up out of the blue line
dormant and then all of a sudden it
becomes active.
I had a bunch of health decisions
because to kind of show up in my
twenties and I mean I started,
I'm like alright,
I got to start taking care of myself.
Started going to the gym,
run a few marathons,
lost a lot of weight and like even when
I was suddenly at a healthy weight,
it was like I couldn't stop losing
weight because my mate,
my intestines just weren't absorbing
anything.
And that's not a,
that's not a thing you see coming or
like I'm at a healthy wise and this
stopping and it was,
it was not good.
But you know,
eventually it was funny because the
gluten trend,
how or the anti gluten trend had already
showed up and a doctor suggested to me,
well have you tried going gluten free?
And I'm like,
oh that's a silly fad.
Three months later diagnosed with CELIAC
disease.
I'm like,
if I hadn't been so skeptical of
everything,
think gluten free is a fad.
I don't think gluten is the best thing
for your body.
It's okay every now and then,
but I think that essentially what you're
getting when you're processed grains
is you're getting something.
Your body's kind.
It's kind of alien.
The bondo doesn't exactly know what to
do with it.
Well,
there doesn't seem.
Here's things.
Tests keeps showing.
There doesn't seem to be a problem with
gluten.
If you don't have celiac disease and
it's
what does that mean by a problem?
Is it like for optimizing your health?
Is it something that you should have in
your diet all the time,
or is it something that mean it really
does convert to sugar.
Everything converts to sugar.
Your body converts everything in some
way,
shape or form into usable fuel,
and the usable fuel is eventually
glucose or Nad Ph.
there's everything in your body gets
converted to sugar when you use do you
feel,
but if you eat a piece of salmon or if
you had a bowl of pasta,
it's a very different reaction how your
body absorbs these two things.
It's a,
yes,
this is,
this is true because all calories
aren't,
aren't the same as they both get
absorbed to sugar,
but avoiding gluten and switching over
to say,
uh,
you know,
all rice,
uh,
isn't,
you know,
that's not going to change a for that
all that much in your body in terms of
what's in terms of the biochemical
mischief and unless you have a gluten
allergy,
like that's none of that yet
the sensitivities.
But there's also a level.
So that too,
right?
Like there's some people where it's like
mildly,
minorly irritating and there's some
people that have extreme issues with it.
Well,
here's at this point,
and this is why I always say at this
point in our scientific knowledge,
scientific knowledge can evolve and we
can learn new things.
Uh,
you know,
at one point the thing that started off
the whole gluten trend,
uh,
was a kind of poorly,
a poorly designed study where they had a
small sample size of people and they
designed it just to test,
you know,
gluten versus a non,
a diet without gluten.
And they came to the conclusion that
about 20 percent of people just based on
this very small study had a bad reaction
to gluten and well,
these people came in saying they had
stomach problems.
Now these people,
it turned out they looked at it and
said,
there's no.
There's no.
Afterwards assigned to saul sat back and
said,
why we're only about one percent of
people having celiac disease.
And then all of a sudden 20 percent of
people are running around like glutens
making their Dick flies off a fly off.
This is,
there's something up here.
So they made a better design study and
they took out common core.
They did,
you know,
Kinda double blind did a,
a better design.
Instead of just say we're going to take
out all these other causes of
gastrointestinal distress and we're
going to try and make this double blind,
and they figured out it was the fodmap,
so it was there were these short chain
illegal saccharide second pull water
into the gut and cause some
gastrointestinal distress and it was
really closer to between like one and
about five percent of people that were
having any issues with gluten.
Now the problem is that what was causing
that though,
the gastrointestinal distress in the.
In the one to five percent,
so one percent is celiac disease for
sure.
One percent.
Yeah.
His across the board with people.
One percent is celiac that is fairly
high.
Now here's the thing that that higher
percent of people that two to five.
Here's the question now they're still
trying to figure out why some people
seem to have an with gluten.
Now,
I could be wrong on.
This is just off the top of my head what
I remember from the study,
but I've had to it a few times,
so I think my knowledge is accurate.
Feel free to fact check me out at home,
um,
but the,
the thing with those extra percent,
they're trying to figure out why they
might have an issue with gluten because
they,
you know,
like wheat is,
you think of it as a carb heavy thing,
right?
And gluten is a protein,
so that other few percentage of people,
they're trying to figure out why the
gluten a does it because gluten is in a
few other things.
It's in barley,
raw and rye.
Uh,
so what they figured out is that this is
the going theory right now.
Gluten can cause a small,
uh,
a reaction in the stomach where you
produce this protein called Zonulin that
can cause an increase in inflammation.
This seems to be,
and this is what I,
this has only been one study that I've
read on it.
It seems to be relatively new.
They're still looking into it.
So there's a chance that people might be
in the two to five percent that can
handle it because of that.
Um,
it could be another component of the
wheat barley,
rye that's causing it,
but gluten in and of itself,
it's not,
you know,
it's unless you are one of those people
that has an actual reaction to it,
perfectly fine,
go on to have,
you know,
go have a sandwich.
So,
but you know,
if you want one,
but I,
you know,
I cut back my carbs pretty heavily over
the last couple years and I've had
really good results whether it's,
I mean if you're someone who's trying to
build muscle,
you know,
I just think that just eventually it
becomes too much sugar.
So much sugar in your body if you're
eating a lot number.
Back when you said that food pyramid and
the bottom of the food pyramid was all
breads.
I mean that's kind of interesting
because that's like stealing like Dr
Seuss books that are read to my kids.
It's like,
wow,
they haven't figured this out yet.
It was supposed to eat that much bread
and pasta.
It's not supposed to be the most thing.
It's.
And it's funny.
I think one of the funny parts of that
is,
is that back in the day when that was
made,
I think slices of bread were much
smaller.
I think I,
I,
I think that's part of it because I just
think people didn't know as much back
then as well.
I think that's part.
I think there are a few things that are
going on with that.
One is that we're really bad at counting
calories and we,
uh,
we were chatting a little bit before he
showed up,
um,
is that there are,
they now have a way of tracking how many
calories people had taken a day through
this drink that can,
uh,
I forget exactly how it works,
but you can take a drink and it will
count the number of calories you've had
in about the last 24 hours.
And they've found there's this,
I forget,
I forget exactly how it works.
It's,
I'll find,
I'll shoot you the article after this,
but this was a,
they,
it was,
God,
I need to find this article.
But it was,
they,
they could do this.
And they were tracking how registered
Dietitians versus,
uh,
you know,
average Joe would,
could Qa because they were,
you know,
you count down how many calories you had
an a day,
a registered dietician who,
you know,
really well trained on dietetic type
stuff versus average person counting
their calories.
The dietitian was off by about 200
calories.
A average person was off by about 500
interact with our guests about what they
were.
I mean,
they were talking to bad 100,
over several thousand,
which is what most people think about
it.
If you're trying to lose weight and
you're the average person and you're off
by 500 calories and that's how.
And you're supposed to,
you know,
in the course of a week to lose one
pound,
you're supposed to have a 500 calorie
caloric deficit.
There's your deficit.
It's not there anymore.
So people are really bad at tracking
their calories and they're really bad at
knowing what a portion size is.
So one of the best ways I've seen from
the personal trainers that I,
that I confer with is weighing out your
food.
It's much harder to make a mistake.
That is a good way.
Another way is there's a bunch of
companies,
I don't have any affiliation with any of
them,
but there's a bunch of companies that
make prepackaged meals that are healthy
and they.
They'll tell you exactly what the
portion sizes are and exactly how many
calories are in and what the nutrients
are in and are in that package and
that's a good way to do it too.
So there's no guesswork.
Yeah,
and it's,
here's one of the other things like I
don't think carbs as you know in and of
themselves are evil.
I think you have to burn what you take
in.
You have to balance your carbs,
your fats,
your proteins,
and you'll be okay and it really depends
on what you're doing for exercise.
And a lot of people overestimate how
much they move under our under.
Yeah,
overestimate how much they move,
underestimate how much they eat and like
I'm friends with a lot of people in the
fitness community,
a lot of weight lifters and depends on
what they're doing.
If they're on a bulk,
there'll their calories will go up to
3000.
If they're on a cut,
they're like,
I'm on like,
I'm on poverty carbs right now.
So it's like 50 carbs over the course
that you're talking about.
Bodybuilding.
Oh yeah.
It's so unhealthy.
It's crazy that we think of that as a
healthy thing.
It's funny because like during the,
like the year when they're not training
for a competition,
it looks fine and then when they're like
six weeks out from a competition,
it's like they're like,
I have a cup of water a day.
I'm like,
how are you?
This is not good for you.
Well,
it's not good for them during the time
where they're cutting and treading and
that's what I'm talking about.
Like when you see a bodybuilder onstage
and they're shredded and they have zero
body made it down to like probably like
three or four percent or some time for
water.
So unhealthy.
It's like they're,
they're literally on death's door,
but they look amazing.
Like the shredded.
You can see every last in you and fiber
of their muscle,
but that's a someone who's like in a
really bad place.
Kidneys are like that close to passing
to to go and away.
It's not good.
It's definitely not good for your body
when they're in that performance zone.
It's so weird that that's what we really
enjoy.
Looking at those.
The rest of the year though,
they eat.
I mean it's,
my trainer is a,
uh,
is a bodybuilder and it's like what he
has me on for,
for weight loss.
Isn't that crazy?
It's about 1600 calories a day.
I'm a fairly okay balance of proteins,
carbs and fats.
And it's like,
at first he had me on a much higher
amount of carbs.
I'm not losing builder.
And you want to,
he a dietician?
No,
but I've,
uh,
wait,
no,
but I have consulted with a Dietitian
too because I have these,
you know,
these are the people I consult with for
my writing and they were like,
yeah,
that looks all right.
You're not,
you're not anything crazy.
And it's because of my height and weight
that I started with.
At first he had me at 1800.
I'm like,
I'm not quite losing here.
And he's like,
let's go down another couple hundred
dollars.
So it's the way they started out with is
always,
you know,
your wait times 10 and then they bust up
the carbs,
proteins,
fats from there.
Um,
and you know,
if you need to adjust,
go from,
you know,
go from there.
And it's like it started with lifting
because I,
you know,
because I've screwed up my joints so
badly for the amount of running I've
done that,
I'm like,
all right,
I will try weight lifting and it's been
kind of fun.
I've enjoyed,
I've enjoyed learning how to do
so.
You screw your joints up from running
but not from lifting weights.
Tim has been a little easier on my
joints,
joints maybe.
I mean I have,
um,
it's a,
I have a kind of,
a bit of a joint condition.
So their condition,
it's they,
they pop out of the socket.
And was that from um,
it's a,
it's called.
You're hearing all of my medical stuff.
I apologize.
It's called Ehlers Danlos Syndrome.
Do you,
do you want to see it or no?
You can do it.
Yeah,
I can pop my shoulder halfway out.
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
So now most people when they stretch,
they stopped.
Like,
here,
let keep going.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But I've had like,
this one's had threesomes like your
shoulders flexible.
Yeah.
But I mean there's a bunch of those
locations if you can see it's popping a
little bit right there,
but yeah,
it's like my hip hop's partway out
depending on that.
I can't,
I can't really strengthened to keep it
from happening.
The more weightlifting I do,
the less popping it does,
but it's been,
I mean this is way less bad than it was
a few months ago before,
like you could visibly see the pop,
like you can still feel it,
but it's,
there's the problem with being hyper
mobile like that is your,
uh,
you leave yourself open to a lot of
different injuries from a,
you know,
from like basic movement can make
something snap.
And it's,
this goes back
to what we're talking about when it
comes to people that have back issues
and one of the things that has been like
super beneficial for me is exercising my
back,
yoga and doing a bunch of different
things,
stretching and making sure that my core
and my spine are very strong and that's
something that kind of gets ignored by a
lot of people that have back issues.
It's like one of the reasons why you
probably have a back issue,
whether it's a herniated disc or a
bulging disk,
is that your back is not strong enough
to sustain whatever load you're putting
on it.
Whatever exercise you're doing,
whatever movement you're doing that's
causing it to pop out of place,
the issue is most likely that you are
not strong enough.
And a lot of that comes from a sedentary
lifestyle,
comes from sitting at a desk all the
time,
comes from poor posture.
There's a variety of different factors
that are not addressed by chiropractors
or by other people.
And if they are addressed by a
chiropractor,
well that's one good thing that they're
telling you.
I mean,
it still doesn't take away from where
this whole thing started.
Yeah.
And I mean it's not,
it's not always the case of back
injuries come from that,
like sometimes it's just you did like
your,
your disc was gonna degenerate that was
written into,
that was written into your life like
you're,
it's,
my boyfriend
did nothing to screw up his back and
just a distorted degenerating and he was
a,
he was a rock climber and there was no
known injury.
Just it happened.
Uh,
and you know,
like I'm.
How do you know that though,
when you're talking about someone having
an issue with their disc,
is it from continual use?
Is it because they're not stretching?
Is it because they didn't have enough
strength in the back?
I mean,
those are all really valid questions and
it's like there's you,
you never know what,
you never know what's going to be the
cause of it beforehand.
And that's why preventative medicine is
hard.
But that's why I always say get to the
gym and lift some weights.
It will at least if they're,
if you're someone who is prone to having
a backend issue issue because you know,
there are some people who are prone to
it get,
what does that mean?
Why would they be prone to.
Well,
in my case I have scoliosis as a part of
the,
um,
as a part of Stan loads.
So that's,
that's why I say prone to it because you
don't,
a lot of times prone to disc
degeneration.
It's someone would be prone to the
degenerative disc disease.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's,
um,
actually I don't,
I,
I'm not sure if that's disputed thing.
Yeah,
I'm much,
I really don't know off the top of my
head.
So I don't know if that's a,
if that's something that,
um,
that you're like,
if that's written into your dna or if
that's something that you injure and it
just gets worse.
That's a lot of it.
Yeah.
That's what I've been talking to people
that work on people that have bulging
discs and doctors that are.
I mean there's some new therapies that
are doing for that now.
One of the things they're doing is
they're injecting stem cells directly
into the risks.
Yeah.
It's very new and they're doing it on
some fighters.
Oh,
I'd love to see how that pans out.
Well,
they've got some really promising
results.
Apparently they've just started it
within the last six to eight months.
I mean,
like the,
the biggest issue I have is that I have
A.
I mean it's not a bad enough case of
scoliosis where I need surgery or a back
brace.
It's just enough to be inconvenient,
so it's like I'm.
My big thing I'm doing is all right.
If I can lift and keep my back strong,
it will stop me from having surgery
eventually.
And back surgery is just,
almost never a good thing to hear
because they're always there when you
fix something surgically.
They're just almost always
complications,
especially with your back on.
I'm like,
if I can keep rods out of my pack,
I'll be very happy.
Well,
you know,
I've had some surgeries that were very
effective of knee reconstructions to
both my knees been reconstructed with
me.
It turned out great,
but I have had friends that have had
some back issues,
especially fusions.
Oh,
that had been a big,
big nightmare.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what I'd probably end up with
[inaudible] like middle of my back and
just kind of goes like,
this is not something I like.
Um,
I've,
I've been told it's something I love
Yoga and I've been told it's not good
for people with ehlers Danlos,
so I'm like,
I don't have been told that by my,
my rheumatologist.
And it's like,
that's like,
but I,
there are still some yoga moves.
I do just be at the end of my workout
because they feel they feel great to
stretch out my back and they feel like
they strengthen my core quite a bit.
So they say it's bad for you because of
how like because of how hyper mobile am,
like it's I'll do downward dog and it
doesn't even feel like it stretches me
because I'm a hyper because I'm so Flexi
to start with and that makes sense.
But you still strengthening those
muscles to support your spine.
What would that be?
Bad.
I got nothing.
I can deadlift and you can't do yoga.
That seems ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
Welcome to a really weird disorder.
This is what it is.
Or is it?
Doctors don't really exactly know what
the fuck they're talking about because
there's a lot of doctors you get injured
and they're like,
well,
you got to stop doing anything.
It's an inside thing where it's like Los
Angeles is a Weirdo disorder.
Like your basically your Collagen is not
able to heal itself or stay kind of in
shape,
uh,
as it used to.
Or as a kid,
a deadlift deadlift has been fine.
Like,
I,
I got it.
It's partially,
you know,
you're,
it's personally that you're not
stretching,
you're,
you're strengthening or your.
I don't know how else to phrase it.
You're not,
you're not stretching your body into
weird positions.
You're,
um,
you're tensing everything.
There's a lot of yoga that's not
stretching and strengthening.
Like when you're,
you know,
you're standing.
Well,
I mean there's a bunch of stretches,
but it's obviously there's a bunch of
things that do stretch your body out,
but there's a bunch of things that are
just strengthening exercises.
You have an f,
you have a really good point.
And I don't.
This is just what I've been told from a
doctor who,
in all honesty,
I don't know how well he knows ehlers
Danlos because it's a rare disorder.
Doctors like to say don't do that.
That's a big thing,
especially with the injured.
Don't do that.
And it's weird because the things
they've told me to do seem so much more,
uh,
intense.
Then Yoga,
it's,
I mean,
I've been told go ahead and bite,
go ahead and uh,
and a deadlift.
Go ahead and,
and for Fuck Sake,
they told me I can rock climb,
which is a thing that's one of my other,
uh,
exercise.
Eat things.
But Yoga they've said is off limits and
it's because of yoga.
I mean this is the problem.
Like when people say don't do yoga,
I always think they think of somebody
like bending over and touching the back
of their head onto their feet.
I think the reason is because they know
how flexible I started at,
so they think I'm going to pull
something out more because of how like
how much I'll push the condition that's
already there and I think that's the
concern.
So the problem with someone saying don't
do yoga.
Well Yoga encompasses a tremendous
amount of different movements and it's
very,
it's,
I find it really strengthening,
like,
and I was surprised because like I used
to,
I used to be kind of that runner chick
who was like,
I don't have time for yoga,
it's boring.
And then I started trying it of all
people.
My boyfriend tried,
dragged me to a yoga class with him and
I left and I'm like,
I am destroyed.
That was the hardest thing I've ever
fucking done.
Like,
oh my God,
my arms were dead afterwards.
It's very hard now.
What made you decide to write this
chiropractic article and what's been the
feedback from it?
Oh God,
I'm so my,
like my,
my editor and this is the editor that I
worked with at,
at Gawker,
at cosmo and now she's,
you know,
at,
at the outline and I love writing there.
Uh,
and we had talked about doing one on
Kairos for ages.
We got to the outline and it was like,
what are we,
what do we have on the table for next
one?
She was like,
wanting to do Kairos.
I'm like,
fuck,
yes,
I do.
What was your thoughts on it before you
wrote the article?
Before I wrote the article,
I knew that the guy who had,
I knew that a lot of Kairos did a lot of
crazy things.
I knew they adjusted infants that they
had claimed I knew about the vertebral
subluxation theory and that,
that was bullshit.
Um,
and I knew that a lot of them on social
media,
we're crazy.
Like one of the people I reported on was
billy Demoss,
uh,
and he,
um,
that he thinks chem trails are real.
He's,
he's all,
he's a whole cluster of fucks.
Um,
and he,
um,
and so,
oh my God,
like,
it's some of the,
some of the like if you,
if he's a real guy,
if you're bored,
go for like go for 10 minutes and read
up on billy demoss.
He's fun.
Um,
and it's just,
he's.
And it's funny because I was not,
I'll get into that in a minute,
but like we,
um,
I learned a lot doing this because I
didn't realize that a DD Palmer,
the guy who invented it,
he,
he got most of his information from
doing seances with a dead doctor.
That blew my mind.
I'm like,
I had to.
I know it's late and I'm a little high
right now,
but I had to have hallucinated that
like,
you know,
read it again the next morning.
I'm like,
nope,
that's for real.
Like it was.
And nobody in chiropractic questions
this when they go to Dr. we were telling
me this before the show and I stopped
you and said,
let's talk about this during the show
when you said you've talked to
chiropractors that we're in the middle
of chiropractic school and they read
about this stuff and they were like,
what in the fuck?
It's sort of like that Gypsy going clear
that scientology documentary that was a
good one,
but like scientology scientology with a
given the written notes by l Ron
Hubbard.
And he's like,
what in the fuck is this and your
$300,000 in and you can't leave.
So I got two emails from chiropractors
and I,
it's like I couldn't,
you know,
put their names out publicly.
But I got two emails from chiropractors
and I checked in and I'm like,
these are indeed chiropractors.
I went to their websites.
They were absolutely on the level that
said they went to chiropractic school
and part way through they realized it
was all shit.
One of them even said they wouldn't
refer people to a chiropractor like it
was nutty.
And one of the guys,
um,
he sent me to a forum for like in which
chiropractor's bitch about the field of
chiropractic.
It's there.
And they were like,
which part of this is bullshit?
You guys believe in the vertebral
subluxation theory.
And they're like,
no,
subluxations don't exist.
Like,
you know,
if you want to do this ethically just
cry,
you know,
take people in who have injuries,
try to do some physical therapy,
get them stronger and get them out and
as few sessions as you can.
So they're essentially unlicensed
physical therapy.
And like,
it's funny because I'll occasionally
pass by a chiropractic clinic where I
see them saying back injuries work
injuries,
um,
you know,
sports,
physical therapy.
And I'm like,
okay,
if I ever wanted to go to a chiropractor
because I lost my mind and couldn't find
a physical therapist,
that's the type I would go to.
But you know,
if you see them advertising magic
crystals and aura healing,
fucking run,
run.
Like this is the,
there are a few of them out there.
And I looked at one of the guys'
websites who emailed me and there was an
Faq.
It's like,
do you have to keep coming back forever?
No,
we try to get you out in as few sessions
as possible.
I'm like,
oh,
I have hope.
But like,
there's,
there's a woman who is,
the of it is bullshit.
It's like even if you're trying to get
me out as few sessions as possible,
you're still like.
But there was a.
it's funny,
there's a woman,
her name is Britt Marie Hermes.
She was,
uh,
she went to school to be a natural path
and she graduated,
became a naturopath and she realized
after a short period of time that it was
all bullshit like naturopathic doctor
and she's like,
we can't actually treat people.
We have to send people to real doctors.
The advice we're giving is all based on
misdirection and complete shit.
And I,
I'm so in awe of the fact that she went
through this.
She like,
and these people,
one of the things they said was,
you know,
I was in all this debt.
I figured,
you know,
I'm like,
Paul Haggis,
you know,
I'm already here.
May as well keep going.
Britt said,
you know,
it doesn't matter.
I realized I was in a profession based
on bullshit.
I had to leave.
He did have some people that you talked
to that were chiropractors that we're in
the middle of it and they realized it
was bullshit and they to stay and they
stayed because what the fuck do I do?
I have to get my money back for my
student loans and I'm like,
you know what,
you could have gone like,
you weren't.
You can get like,
I mean,
I say this as someone who got into a lot
of debt for my real degree,
go and get another degree.
If you're smart enough to have gotten at
least your undergrad before you went to
Palmer chiropractic.
Have an undergrad before you go to
Palmer?
Chiropractor?
I believe so,
given that it's a doctorate program now,
one of the guys that I went to Undergrad
with,
no,
he was,
he was smart.
He had a biology degree and he was there
on scholarship.
He was one of the smarter kids in the
buyer program.
Like there was,
there was,
he could have gotten a doctorate if he
wanted.
He went to Palmer.
Um,
you know,
same school as some of the,
uh,
Kairos in this article and it was funny,
like one of my editor that I worked with
on this piece asked me,
so the doctors that you're concentrating
on in this piece,
are they the exception to the norm?
As is how regular chiropractors work.
I'm like,
let me go look at my friend from
college's a little chiropractic page.
And I looked,
he adjusts infants.
He claims that he can stop bed wedding
from adjusting a seven year old.
I'm like,
oh my God.
this is.
And like I,
I'm sitting here going,
my God like this,
this guy that I went to school with who
seemed,
you know,
he was smart.
He was like,
this is,
I was,
I was kind of like.
And I wasn't,
it was hard to be mad.
I was just disappointed in this person
that I just stuck in this system.
I mean,
is that like a bunch of people that are
also doing the same thing and they just
kind of get caught up in this idea?
I think they hear it from a bunch of
people who they think are experts like
their teachers and they're going,
no,
this is accepted so we're going to take
it.
It's like,
you know what if you like,
if I saw people in science like because
I,
I promote a lot of things,
you know,
we might disagree on,
but you know,
I promote a lot of ideas in science that
I've seen the evidence for and I've seen
a lot of it and we disagreed.
I'm seeing some dietary things I would
guess like,
cause you know,
we can,
we can hash that,
like what are,
I don't know,
what are your thoughts on Gmos?
Genetically Modified Foods is apparently
almost everything that you buy at the
supermarket.
Okay.
What did we agree on that then?
Probably,
and it's like I think they know you by
every orange.
If you look at a piece of corn,
oh it's organic.
That Shit is genetically modified.
It's been modified for 100 years.
They're going to make me cry.
Tears.
I've,
I've talked.
You had Kevin Folta was.
I was so happy I had him on because he's
never in California.
We went out for dinner that night,
so it takes a lot of shit because
Monsanto is funded some of the studies
that they've done,
but the studies are real and the studies
of.
I mean,
you can see the results.
They're not manipulated.
Yeah.
Kevin,
it's.
Well actually no,
they funded his communication program so
that he can come out and do things like
this and they never funded any of his
research.
That's right.
You're right.
I misspoke.
No,
no,
it's fine.
It's a.
But you know what,
here's a.
and this is what,
where he got a lot of shit was um,
was that he said I have nothing to do
with Monsanto.
Um,
and like I think if he just said,
you know,
what they fund my communication program
but they don't have anything to do with
my research.
Nobody would have A.
I think people still would have been
mad,
but I think people would have been far
less mad and I feel so bad that he went
through everything with that because
there was anything with Monsanto.
It's tricky.
I mean,
I just took a tour there and I got hate
mail like,
and it's,
I mean we were so careful because I was
out there for other business,
um,
and they were like,
oh,
you're going to be out in,
in Missouri,
come have a tour.
Like they didn't pay to the star and I
had so much fun like it was,
there was,
they have a lot of really cool tech
there and if you're ever in the area
they'd gladly show you around.
So they're there.
They were nice to me and responding.
One of the,
one of the rumors that I heard about
that was that they only have organic
food in the cafeteria.
I'm like,
I'm taking,
I'm taking my camera around and taking
pictures of everything.
The word organic is such a weird way
too.
It's like what's organic and what's not
now it's like,
it's very clear definition.
Organic uses pesticides and that's
something I think people see.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean I was the whole point of organic.
You don't use pesticides or you know,
I'm sure there are some organic farmers
that don't use any google this.
What defines organic food?
Let's find out what is the accepted
definition,
organic food.
Do you want to hear it from me?
And then from Google to see if I'm at
all right,
so organic food works by certain farming
stand or agricultural standards and they
can use certain pesticides.
In most cases these pesticides are
derived from natural sources.
I'm not always,
but most of the time and some of these
pesticides include pesticides like
wrote,
known and the [inaudible] and also have,
if you're familiar with bt corn,
um,
the bt toxin is also used in organic
farming for because it's a naturally
occurring,
a toxin,
it can be used and sprayed topically on
organic produce.
So a lot of these are the things that we
think of as just conventional farming
practices.
Definitely use in organic farming.
It doesn't make it any better or worse.
It just,
in a lot of cases it's a little more
expensive partially because of the
certification process and partially
because it uses older farming techniques
that need a little more land,
that type of stuff.
It also uses a till farming practices
that you know,
digs up the ground a bit more and
Kimberly's a little more co two,
so in general I tend to.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Simply stated,
organic produce or other ingredients are
grown without the use of pesticides.
Synthetic fertilizers,
excuse me,
hold on.
Sewage sludge,
genetically modified organisms or
ionizing radiation.
Animals that produce meat,
poultry,
eggs,
and dairy products.
Do not take antibiotics or growth
hormones to us.
Hold on,
sorry.
The U.
S,
d,
a national organic program defines
organic as follows.
Organic food is produced by farmers who
emphasize the use of renewable resources
and the conservation of soil and water
to enhance environmental quality for
future generations.
Organic meat,
poultry and eggs and dairy products are
made from animals that are given no
antibiotics or growth hormones.
Organic food is produced without using
most conventional pesticides.
There we go.
Fertilizer is made with synthetic
ingredients or sewage sludge
bioengineering or ionizing radiation
before a product can be labeled organic
and quotes a government approved
certifier inspects the farm where the
food is grown to make sure the farmers
following all the rules necessary to
meet USD.
Organic standards,
no.
The one thing on there that will
disagree with what their first paragraph
as they say,
without the use of pesticides.
In the second paragraph it says organic
food is produced without using most
conventional pesticides.
You see that slight little slight of
hand
because one of them is theirs and the
other one is USD.
A little slider.
I mean if you.
If,
if I may ask,
would you.
Would you like to do.
Google will hold on a second.
Let's Google what pesticides can be used
and still make it organic.
Exactly what I was going to request a
organic pesticides approved for use in
the u.
s we go now what?
What are the fears of pesticides?
Right.
People worried about toxins getting into
their food,
getting in their body and cancer.
I
understand that fear partially because I
went through it quite a bit,
like when I got sick a few years ago,
like my first symptom wasn't celiac
disease.
It wasn't my joints popping out.
I got the worst headache of my life one
day at it.
Never went away like that.
That'll make you scared to death of
everything around you.
Like I went organic,
I went Vegan,
I went.
I'd cut everything out of my diet
because I was scared that,
you know,
you get,
you feel like you're getting stabbed in
the eye constantly.
You're going to cut everything out of
your diet.
This happened all at once.
One day worse had it.
I was working and at the time I wasn't
working in the pesticide lab yet.
I was working in a drug analysis lab.
I'm worried that that was what was going
on that absorbs that or something.
Well,
it was.
I was the thing that I was worried
because I was.
At the time I was,
I was.
There was much more than the hits a day
It was much more of me and there is here
today.
I was,
I'm five,
nine and I at the time weighed almost
250 pounds.
I,
I needed to lose a little of me,
but it was like,
all right,
I'm eating shitty food.
I should probably try eating healthier.
But I mean,
nevermind just more salads.
I'm like,
I went organic.
I went,
I just cut everything out of my diet.
So there was a bunch of issues.
It was,
it wasn't terry as well.
I mean,
yeah,
like I cut a lot of things out,
started working out everything,
but you know,
what,
I still needed medication because it
turned out there was just um,
a uh,
it was just,
I had and we figured out the headache
was linked into the ehlers Danlos
Syndrome and there are some to,
to clarify everything.
Some people,
when they have one autoimmune,
they can tend to cluster.
So there's,
that's,
I,
I was lucky color 1 million.
Um,
but that was,
that was the thing with it.
But I tried,
you know,
I looked into this and I fell for all of
it.
Like so,
all of the pesticides are killing you.
It's the toxin.
So I mean,
I understand the fear of the people who
were like,
I need to cut toxins out of my diet.
Do.
Is there any foundation in truth?
I mean,
nothing bad for you?
Well,
no pesticide.
Here's the thing,
there is a little bit of truth that
sells.
The lie is what I will give this because
I,
you know,
I used to work with bulk quantities of
pesticides at my last lab and that was
kind of what sealed the deal for me that
these when they're in your food are not
going to hurt you because the amount of
testing we had to go through and the
amount of regulation,
I think regulation in this case is a
good thing because it will stop a bad
pesticide,
uh,
for making it to market.
And I want that regulation there because
I eat the food too.
I don't want anyone's child to ever get
hurt from something that,
that me or another,
like I don't work there anymore.
But you know that,
that I had any work and getting on the
market,
I don't want to ever want that to be the
case,
but once upon a time the pesticides we
had on the market were much less
targeted to hurting the weeds and could
hurt people too,
like arson are cynical's a sulfuric
acid.
Those were early pesticides,
Paris,
green,
totally toxic,
especially to,
uh,
to the farmers and to the,
even to the farm equipment,
the stuff we have now far less toxic and
I mean people used far less though
toxic.
It's in me.
I'm going to qualify this answer and I
mean I'm not,
I'm not qualifying it to back off from
it,
but everything is toxic in some dosage
so water will kill you.
But I mean,
so roundup is one that people are really
scared of it.
It's one that a lot of people know
about.
There is a great graph on,
on the showing how less toxic it is than
the,
than the pesticides that replaced
because we weren't,
we didn't go from using no pesticide to
using roundup.
Um,
and I know someone's gonna correct me
saying it's an herbicide,
but um,
herbicide is pesticides the blanket
term,
all things that killed a stuff and
farming.
Um,
so before,
um,
before roundup,
I believe the one we used with Cyanna
azine I could be wrong on this,
but the one we used before roundup was
in terms of the ld 50,
the lethal dose for about 50 percent of
the population.
It was 10 times higher than roundup and
now we barely sell any of it.
So we just,
the issue just lethal dose or toxic
toxicity that affects your body cancer.
It's,
I,
and I understand that's a question that
people keep coming back to and part of
the reason that people are suspicious of
it is because of its use with the GMO
and the,
these things go through hundreds of
tests and years of testing.
And because of the suspicion with
roundup,
it's gone through continual testing,
like they've tested to see if it,
uh,
if it accumulates in breast milk,
it does not.
Um,
they've tested to see if it causes
cancer,
doesn't seem to.
Um,
and they've tried,
they've used it at higher doses of mice
and rats.
They've,
they've,
uh,
they've tested in humans.
It's been on the market for 30 years,
mean like it's been in the population or
it's been used now for I believe,
25 years and there doesn't seem to be
the only,
the only apparent increase in cancer is
because we're living longer now.
And when you have any population that
lives longer,
you have increased incidence of cancer.
Like we're not dying from polio anymore.
So we're dying from something like
unfortunately we're not gonna live
forever.
So.
Yeah.
But,
so,
um,
there's a toxicity issue when it comes
to roundup or when it comes to any sort
of pesticide.
When you're talking about herbicides,
herbicides are what kills the plants,
right?
Kills Weeds,
kills bugs that are pests.
Pesticides are,
it's the blanket term.
Insecticide kills bugs.
So pesticides,
the,
the whole blanket term.
Yep.
Okay.
So what is,
what's the most controversial is that
roundup.
Roundup is controversial and I think the
reason that it became controversial is
because people heard,
all right,
you have to genetically modify the
plants so that the roundup doesn't kill
the plant and it's this whole thing just
to make money for Monsanto and how dare
you make money.
Um,
and that's,
I think that was why people got mad was
because of the genetic modification.
Lincoln with roundup.
Um,
and it's,
you know,
it's a new technology or it's one of
the,
it's a newer technology and it kind of
made people a little aware of farming
for the first time and net.
Like I go to farming conferences a lot
of times to talk about how to
communicate agriculture and I'll sit
down and ask farmers,
you know,
what are you plant,
why are you planting it,
what do you think of Gmos you use
roundup and do you buy from people other
than do you buy for Monsanto?
And do you buy from people other than
Monsanto?
And that handful of questions will tell
me.
Well,
I mean,
if I,
I wish I had more videos of this,
but like there's,
there's a video at some point on my site
with two farmers who buy from Monsanto
and buy from other companies and one of
the reasons I asked is because there's a
rumor on the Internet that if you buy
from Monsanto,
you can only buy for Monsanto.
Just not true,
uh,
that,
you know,
every genetically modified crop is,
uh,
is,
you know,
just is made to be roundup ready.
Again,
not true,
uh,
that you know,
that people are,
you know,
are being,
um,
that people are dying of cancer from
just being around roundup.
And recently they found that one of the
reports that went through the IRC,
the cancer,
the place that declares things
cancerous,
you know,
on their,
Group A,
one to a two hub,
um,
cancer,
uh,
classifications.
One of the reports was falsified that
declared roundup a cancerous.
Now we also have to follow that up by
the person who is.
I'm I have to hunt down this report,
but the person who was trying to say
roundup is cancer because of a little
bit of suspicion around it because it's
been people have kicked around that it's
causing cancer or you know that your
spleen to turn radioactive for you know,
forever.
And it's.
So is this like chem trails type thing?
A little bit like one of the things that
people talk about in terms of conspiracy
theory and it just,
it gets put into the public sphere so
much that people start to believe it.
And here's the.
If I saw from evidence that roundup had
caused issues,
I would say right away just get rid of
it,
take it off the market and I keep on not
seeing from evidence of it.
Like one of the.
There was a study,
there's this group moms across our moms
across America and it's.
I take,
I always get my scientific information
for mom groups on the Internet,
but this group decided to do a breast
milk study to see if roundup accumulated
in breast milk.
And the way the study was done was they
just had women indiscriminately sending
containers of breast milk,
uh,
to,
to them.
And they declared like the amount of
roundup to be ridiculously high in the
breast milk.
And I'm like,
did they just tell women to spray pump
bottles of,
uh,
of roundup into these containers and
then test it.
But it turned out.
And this just from knowing how
analytical techniques work,
like I used to design the techniques by
which we extracted a target pesticides
from a matrix and,
you know,
analyze them on our,
on our big overpriced machinery.
But the,
a woman who is a breast milk,
a researcher out of a University of
Washington was like,
this doesn't seem right.
So she designed an experiment to test if
roundup was accumulating and breast
milk.
And she had it verified by an out by an
independent lab,
um,
and it,
and they tested women specifically who
worked in agriculture and she had their
breast milk tested specifically on days
where they were spraying roundup and
there was nothing found.
Yeah.
But that's someone who's not necessarily
eating the food that someone is working
with the food working with roundup.
Right.
And you would expect that if it was
being sprayed.
Well they go to this way round the issue
though,
interrupt you.
But the issue is people eating it.
It's both.
Think about it this way.
If it's in the food supply,
um,
wouldn't they be eating as well?
I don't know.
I don't know what their diet is like if
you're,
if you're getting it from people's
breast milk and those people say there's
roundup in my breast milk and I've been
eating genetically modified crops.
It's.
Well the other question is if these are
the people that are following a moms
across America and their whole thing is
that roundup is the devil.
So you think they're falsifying
evidence?
I think that it was not a well
controlled experiment and it will be
interesting to see,
um,
to see how the experiment would come out
if the person who runs moms across
America is and honeycut would work
would,
how it would look if zen were to look in
on every step of the process with a
Shelly Mcguire,
Dr Kelly Mcguire to see that,
uh,
you know,
these people ate food that should have
been sprayed with roundup and worked in
the field and then at the end to see if
their breast milk came out with nothing
in it.
So I think,
don't you,
don't you think that there'd be more
likely to be some sort of conspiratorial
collusion with people that actually work
in farms that use roundup rather than
someone who's just checking the breast
milk.
It's like,
wouldn't you think that like if
someone's trying to prove that roundup
isn't showing up in breast milk and
you've got a bunch of people that
they're living relies on using roundup?
Well,
the farm workers themselves,
they'd want to be safe.
Right?
And I say that as someone who's worked
at a pesticide company and when I worked
there,
I mean I was,
I was just an analytical chemist.
I'm not someone who had any investment
in keeping that company safe from being
yelled at.
I want it to be safe from the stuff I
was working with.
But I found it weird that you feel like
there's some sort of conspiracy with
these moms that are checking their
breast milk,
but you don't think there might possibly
be some shenanigans involved in the
people that actually need roundup to
make a living.
It's no,
I understand what you're saying for
sure.
But part of the reason why I think that
Dr Mcguire would have conducted a better
study was number one,
in independently verified a number two
knows how to do collection evidence are
not ambulance a specimen collection
accurately and number three,
monitored and independently verified
from an outside lab.
So it's like we don't have.
And when,
uh,
when moms across America was asked,
to show their data and how they
collected the samples they didn't give,
they weren't willing to,
to share,
uh,
their,
all of their data on how specimen
collection,
uh,
was,
was excuse for not sharing that I don't
recall off the top of my head,
but they weren't like,
it's,
it seems suspicious to me that they
weren't willing to disclose that when
you're,
when you do an experiment,
everything.
And I mean I used to work under glp
standards,
which basically you throw out a glove,
you have to write it down.
And that's,
that's part of the standards and how you
get,
you know,
a chemical into a,
into use in agriculture is you really
have to be careful and,
and forthcoming on how you do your work.
Which was the amount of pesticides that
they in breast milk uniform.
It's,
I believe that I didn't,
I don't think there were only testing
for roundup and they found there to be.
They didn't find there to be even trace
amounts,
which I was kind of surprised that I
would have expected something in the
moms across America stuff they found a
lot.
Yeah.
What was the uniform?
Was it,
did everybody have like a similar
amount?
No,
they found in the amount of varied and
they were,
they were so high.
It was like,
it was just somebody dripped some in
there.
It was suspicious and that's why I was
like,
I don't like that was why I didn't buy
it.
The other thing is they used a
technique,
a,
an analytical technique that was used
for water and that's why I'm like,
this is not like not all techniques you
use for all work for all chemical
matrices.
So that's another reason why,
uh,
you know,
a different lab,
uh,
was probably better equipped to handle
it.
One specifically that analyzes breast
milk.
Um,
so it's,
I think like the other thing is,
you know,
that the other lab,
the other lab kind of had a bias going
in because their whole thing is how
roundup is bad.
So lab,
it's like,
I just want to know if,
you know moms are being harmed,
if there's breast,
if there's something in the,
in the breastmilk that seems like a lab
that,
you know,
went in just wanting to know the other
lab went in saying I hate roundup.
So if I would have,
if,
if roundup had been found in a,
in the test that Dr Mcguire's lab had
done,
I would have happily accepted those
results because you know,
it almost wouldn't.
It would have surprised me not in the
least if it had been found,
but I was kind of,
I was Kinda glad that there was nothing
there because it means that,
you know,
babies aren't getting a concentrated
dose of this just because you know,
you don't want extraneous chemicals
going into the food supply.
Only testing people that worked in these
farms.
Is that,
was that the idea?
I think they did.
I don't remember off the top of my head,
but I know one of the people,
one of the groups,
they did test for women on testing days,
but they go to this way.
They're not just spraying it.
They're also,
you know,
possibly eating food that's been a,
that's added on there.
That's possibly,
it would be more interested in seeing it
100 percent sure that these people were
eating food that makes sense with
roundup and that doesn't make sense to
me that they didn't do that.
It's,
I'm,
you know,
I,
I'd have to,
I want to have a look at the study again
myself,
just to be,
just to be sure of what the weather
conditions were before.
I'm curious about both tests.
Have a,
have a look.
Um,
we can have a quick peek a after it for
Dr Maguire breastmilk roundup study,
you know,
the whole thing seems a little weird to
me.
It's weird that one group test group
test.
Not at all.
It's,
it is.
I'm going to say it is easy to screw up
a study,
uh,
using,
um,
if you're not sure the parameters you're
supposed to use in an analytical,
uh,
in,
in a chemical analysis a thing because
you can have interfering species that
come up with the same peaks at the same
time.
Uh,
so I'm.
The other thing is,
like I said,
we,
the biggest thing is we don't know the
collection parameters for the one that
mom across America did,
so they won't tell us.
It's the other thing is Dr Maguire was
doing it through a university and she
could've been,
she could've been in a lot of trouble if
she'd a falsified a or data or done or
done a test that was purposefully
misleading.
Right.
So that's what are the pesticides.
Did you google the best asides that are
acceptable
as a firm?
The put them up.
There's a long list somewhere,
but the,
uh,
I had it here.
It's on the usaid or USD,
a good.gov website.
It just,
it's like a standards of what they use
to put stuff on and off of it.
And there are a organic standards that
allow some substances,
but where they're mostly trying to get
out synthetic substances.
However,
there are also some synthetic substances
that are allowed to.
Interesting.
And this is to label something organic,
right?
And then there's a board that votes on
it from time to time.
If somebody wants to bring something up
and disagree that it shouldn't be on
that list.
Isn't that weird though?
I mean,
most people think you say organic.
Most people think there's no pesticides.
Most people think you're just growing
plants.
Yep,
and that's I.
They sell that so well,
don't they?
It's,
for instance,
for Mons pheromones,
pheromones,
pheromones.
Have long been used as effective,
nontoxic ways to confuse insects that
might otherwise infest organic crops,
especially fruit,
so they put some certain smells just
free bugs out.
Likewise,
vaccines for animals are important.
Disease Prevention tools against many
infectious diseases,
blah,
blah.
Especially since antibiotic therapy is
prohibited in livestock.
Picturing an anti-vaxxer staying away
from organic produce because they
vaccinated it against bees.
Well,
you can always grow your own food,
folks,
you know,
and not put anything on it,
but I think large scale domestic
agriculture,
if you're talking about these gigantic
fields,
nothing could be less natural.
It's not normal to have a thousand acres
of corn.
It just doesn't exist in the wild.
And when you do that,
you're going to run into a lot of
problems.
Since I always go back to the argument
of nothing we're doing is natural
anyway.
We're sitting in a,
in an air conditioned studio in
California that we.
We'd probably be.
We'd be dead with a lot of the things
that we don't have.
That's,
that's Kebab food.
There's no food around here.
Where are you growing food?
It was.
No one's grown food anywhere near us.
There's,
there's nothing that we enjoy that
that's natural anymore as natural and
it's God damn delicious.
We got a freezer.
How do you get a freezer?
It's like I like.
You want natural bear attacks?
Asteroids.
Well,
I think there's a little sticker.
Things that come out of trees.
Those are all natural,
so you're going to say stickers or
groups.
It's groups.
Jesus made those himself.
What's
up?
Something on the company that made those
stickers.
I was going to bring this up a second
ago.
Oh,
I went to their website and it's a.
They have this thing called
a digestive solution.
Energy card.
Oh,
Jesus.
All the digestive solution.
Energy card.
What in the fuck is this?
Now?
Look at this.
You can now in all caps,
bold letters,
boosts your body energy signature,
all,
all bold by simply placing this
digestive solution tm energy card,
under your food plate,
holy fuck,
and the beverage of your choice and
receive energy from the card instantly
you motherfuckers.
The energy card has a magnetic strip
embedded in the back that holds
digitally enhanced information that once
your food or beverage comes in contact
with it,
the energy is delivered immediately to
the food and beverage there by boosting
the energy to your food to maximize
their nutrition.
You consume.
You fucking criminals should be in jail.
You guys are monsters.
Gwyneth paltrow just broke as shit.
The digestive energy card,
digestive solution,
ng card is an energetically enhanced
product.
What?
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Hold on a second.
Look at that.
Look at that sentence,
that digestive energy,
the digestive solution.
Energy card is an energetically enhanced
products.
That's shit.
English.
Our engineers have achieved the correct
ratio response of frequency signatures
through a technology that matches the
same energy received from the nutrients
you get from the food you eat and drink.
You know this guys wearing in toe shoes
when he wrote this,
right?
We consume food.
It converts into chemical energy,
which provides a nutritional needs for
energy and growth.
This connection is defined by the laws
of thermodynamics that requires all
humans to burn food for energy.
You guys are fucking cunts.
What is the name of this company?
This is an Alpha biocentric concert.
Warm,
lovely place.
This.
These people are asking.
That's a totally different thing.
A suggested retail price.
Seventy $9.
Oh my God.
The card is guaranteed for two years.
It looks like a credit card fame,
but that's just listening.
It is a credit card.
I mean it's 100 percent bullshit.
God Damn.
How the fuck does someone get away with
this?
This is horrible.
I have no good.
You just imagine the idea that you could
put a card under your food.
It makes your food better.
I'm trying to figure it because they're
saying it energetically enhances it.
Does this mean it adds calories to it or
does its nutrient transfer?
Whatever the fuck those dynamics.
I keep using these words.
I don't think they know what they mean.
There's a lot of people that like to use
those sciencey words,
right?
It's like chiropractors,
subluxations somebody.
They always say that.
I remember them saying that all the time
to one doctor.
He adjusted me five minutes,
right?
One hundred 40 bucks.
Then he goes,
make sure you drink a lot of water.
I'm like,
why?
To wash the fucking taste
out of my mouth.
You asshole.
You didn't do anything.
This is crazy.
The bullshit down.
Yeah.
Wash the bullshit goes,
goes better with what is the response
been?
I mean,
he must have gotten a lot better.
A lot of swearing.
Oh God.
Twitter.
Twitter was an angry.
I'm still getting angry.
Tweets like people that use it or from
chiropractors themselves,
fewer chiropractice.
Some chiropractors and a lot of people
who who love Chiropractic and are mad at
me because I think people think I'm
calling them stupid for using
chiropractor,
but I'm like,
no,
you got you.
You got a lot of us.
I mean it's like I would basically be
calling half my fan base a stupid if,
if that were the case and I'm not.
And I felt kinda bad because a good
friend of mine,
like she like after she gave birth,
she had like a severe enough injury that
she could barely walk and a chiropractor
basically from massaging the area,
got her up and walking and she's like.
And the thing she said to me was,
I'm tired of being called a lemming
moron.
I'm like,
I never use number one.
I never insulted people who use
chiropractic.
And number two,
I definitely didn't.
You use those two words.
And I think people got the impression
that I was calling everyone who used
chiropractor's dumb.
And it's like,
that's never the point of my writing.
It's like you're not the Moron for
falling for this.
They're the assholes for selling it.
Don't even know of.
A lot of them are assholes because I
don't know if a lot of them have even
looked into this.
You know,
I've talked to some chiropractors about
this stuff that's been going on over the
last couple of weeks since your article
and since I did my podcast,
since we've talked about it several
times,
I just don't think they understand the
origins of this
or that it's or the stuff they're
selling isn't considered scientifically
validated
kid and you're getting out of high
school and into college and you know,
you want to get involved in something
therapeutic in chiropractic medicine
seems like a good thing and you start
going to chiropractic school like you
might not even know.
And I,
I really do sympathize with a lot of
chiropractors who are out there.
They have emailed me like,
hey man,
like what you're saying could
potentially destroy my business.
I understand and I sympathize,
but you've got to understand that if I
knew about this and I didn't talk about
it,
that would be more horrible.
I have a responsibility if I find
something out like this,
like the guy who invented as a fucking
quack and a magnetic healer and you're
not really going to medical school.
There's a responsibility that you have
to say something about that.
Yeah,
and I just think people are thinking
about themselves.
They're thinking about,
you know,
hey,
I've got bills and hey,
I've got this and I've got to practice
and I've got this other job.
Yeah.
I don't want to be the guy that tells
you what to do,
but you can't get upset at someone
saying something.
That's if I made up the fact that
chiropractic medicine was founded by a
magnetic healer and he was killed by his
own son.
Do you know the story behind that was
run over by his son.
His son ran him over
with a fucking car and they think you
might've done it on purpose and this son
apparently was a fucking huge fraud and
the son went on to be the one who
promoted chiropractic.
Medicine was really promoted by the sun.
Yeah,
it's in the wikipedia.
Pull up the wikipedia on chiropractic
controversies.
This that.
There's a real,
a theory that the son murdered the dad
and the son murdered the dad to take
over the business and then he's the one
who pushed chiropractic.
Madison,
I think we had to cut it off at some
point because the article was 40,000
words.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Right.
Here we go.
What are you out of here?
Jamie?
Wikipedia.
This is death.
It says there's a book about.
Yeah.
Homecoming parade that sets hilarious
injuries by his son.
Yeah.
He fucking random over his son ran him
over.
Attempted patricide.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's fun.
There was speculation that it was an
accident,
but instead,
wow.
A case of attempted patricide that's.
But that it was not an accident.
No one knows.
So who knows?
I mean,
you're talking about some shit that went
down the 18 hundreds or actually 1913 I
guess.
Huh?
So 1913 Bj Palmer ran over his dad,
dd Palmer and.
Yeah.
And that guy is filled with fucking
problems too.
If you look into him.
The son,
apparently the sun was a massive fraud.
So in a sense,
chiropractic medicine was founded by a
quack and promoted by a fraud and
might've murders dad.
Well,
how the fuck does it get so far?
That's the most stunning thing about it.
It's,
it's a thing where like it,
it took root before,
like,
like I said before,
real medicine was,
was starting and it just,
it kept going like,
well medicine was making attempts at
other things and some of them failed and
some of them stayed.
Like,
think about around that time was when
Bayer was like,
we have a new miracle cure heroin like
that.
There was a lot of shit going on.
Yeah.
So I mean like they weren't teams and
Coca Cola.
Yeah,
like they were trying at real things and
failing,
but at least they were.
They were trying.
Like these guys were like,
hey,
we had a launch check nudge motherfucker
out and that didn't work so well
without the Internet.
People would not have had this
information.
Like when I first started going to
chiropractors was probably 20 years ago.
No one had this information wasn't
available.
No one knew.
You just thought,
oh,
he's a doctor.
It says doctor of Chiropractic.
Oh,
he's a guy who studied chiropractic
medicine
and I love it.
So many of them just say,
doctor.
And you have to dig through their
website for where it eventually says
chiropractic.
How can you fucking call yourself a
doctor if you don't go to medical
school?
Isn't,
shouldn't there be some sort of a
national standard on it?
It's funny because a lot of them,
like I and I,
I dunno if this should bug me or not
because like you'll see dr somewhere and
the,
the mds will say md really carefully or
pediatrician,
although will be very careful to say
what type of doctor they are.
If someone like now I'm very leery.
If I just Dr [inaudible].
I'm like,
all right,
are they had like what breed of doctor
are they?
Do they have a phd?
Do they have,
are they a chiropractor,
league of IC doctrine that I see some
bullshit on their page.
I'm like,
what type of doctor are they?
Because like everyone wants you to think
like,
or I think people just want you to think
that there are medical doctor,
uh,
and that,
that way that title has a lot of weight.
So people will take shit advice if they
see dr period in front of the name.
Bill cosby was a doctor for awhile too.
They took it back.
I apparently people were taking some
drugs from him.
They just didn't know it.
They gave him an honorary doctorate.
Doctorates are also weird.
Right?
Because if you get a doctorate you can
be called a doctor Dr Cosby,
but you don't have to have better.
Also.
We need a new word for that.
It's someone who's got a doctorate.
Shouldn't be a fucking doctor and say I
go back and forth on that one because I
have friends who,
you know,
had their phds and like you're kind of,
you call them doctor and then like when
I think I feel like when they email
people generally in the signature line,
it's,
you know,
it's Joe Schmo Phd.
Like they make sense.
Yeah.
It's like they signed things phd in
general just to not be a dick about it,
but it's like the,
it's.
I feel like putting Dr Blank when you're
a phd.
It's like I feel like it can cause some
confusion.
Dr Laura,
Dr Laura.
She a doctor was a Dr Phil.
Dr Phil's a doctor.
He's not a psychologist or which one of
you is off the top of my head.
I feel like there was a doctorate in
there somewhere or a phd or something
like,
there's so many of them that just don't
have what they say.
It's funny because,
uh,
what's his face?
Dr Oz.
Really good cardiothoracic surgeon.
Bullshit.
Or on TV though.
He's so scary.
Like I sell a miracle cures for weight
loss.
It's gotten.
It's funny because since Congress told
them,
cut the shit.
He's been in Congress.
It's still on TV.
He's been less full of shit but still a
little full of shit because that's our
work.
How do you feel a 45 minute TV show with
complete?
Like,
you know,
just peer reviewed science everyday.
It's hard.
So like,
so you start bullshitting and we're way
more than that.
That's like shilling for selling miracle
Cube is so fucked and it's like the
disappointing thing is like he was.
I mean when I say good,
he was an amazingly good cardiothoracic
surgeon and that's what's disappointing
about this is he used that credibility
of being such a good doctor to be such a
big asshole.
It's like,
why?
Why would you do that to people they
expect we,
we wanted better from you just don't do
that.
Ben Carson,
the guy who's like a serious
neurosurgeon,
he was at anything to earth 10,000 years
old.
He thinks there's grain in the fucking
pyramids,
grain grain.
He was like,
there's great.
And in the pyramids that's not so
shocking that someone would leave some
grain behind but not like filled with
grains.
I think he thought they were silos.
They were ancient silos.
Like it's not that he doesn't mean that
there's like an occasional vase full of
grain.
He means like they were silos and that's
not not accurate.
Were a young earth or it's I.
That might be.
I don't,
I haven't looked too much into them.
I might've made that up,
but I mean it would,
nothing would surprise me with some of
the people.
There are a lot of people who are
extremely smart,
but they close off just giant sections
of their reasoning and understand that
it's hard to find people that are a
hundred percent,
you know,
are very skeptical and very,
uh,
you know,
or,
or critical thinkers and want to be
critical thinkers in every field.
I feel like,
look,
I have this spool.
I'll be really good and really critical
thinking about this,
but motherfucker,
I have this belief and you can't touch
it.
And like that seems to be the case with
a lot of people.
I'm like,
I just want evidence about things.
Show me evidence.
And the big thing is show me where the
balance of evidence says,
like if you give me two articles that
say this and then 10,000 that say this,
I'm like,
I'm over here.
I'm going there.
And I think that's.
I think that's kind of a,
a solid way to,
to evaluate evidence.
Like if you've got a lot of them that
say this and they're.
And they seem solid and backed by a
backed by people who know what they're
talking about.
It just seems to be the,
a good way to evaluate what you're,
you know,
how you're gonna choose your opinions on
something.
It seems like you just really have to do
a lot of research before you form any
opinion on anything.
And it's like,
well that's one of the reasons why I
don't blame people when they don't get
it right right away because I do like.
And this is something I'll do it.
Some of my talks a lot,
I'll say,
you know,
take out your phones and Google a term
that you're not sure about in,
in health or nutrition,
google,
gmos,
sugar,
Google,
you know,
whatever.
And you know,
tell me what the top 10 search results
say.
And you know,
sometimes like,
especially with Gmos for a long time,
the top like eight out of 10 search
results were like,
wow,
this is going to make your Dick fall
off.
And it's like now like it's changed a
little bit because there's been a huge
effort by science writers to get other
words.
This isn't gonna kill you,
but like for,
for awhile,
like how,
you know,
it's so many of the top search results.
So they were horrible.
How hard should,
you know,
just a soccer mom in Iowa have to hunt
to figure out if this is going to kill
her kids.
Like and I,
that's why I really don't blame people
when they get it wrong at first because
this is,
there's so much bad information out
there that it's easy to get the
impression that,
like I said,
the 10,000 articles say it's bad when
it's really just,
you know,
screaming assholes repeating,
the one article that say it's bad.
Well if you just google chiropractic
medicine,
you're not gonna get a lot of fraud
articles.
If you Google Chiropractic is bullshit,
you get your article and then you go
down a rabbit hole and you know,
if you Google chiropractic fraud,
you'll find plenty of stuff on it.
And then the history of chiropractic
medicine is where really unravels and
it's,
it's hard to.
It's like when someone just wants to
know what's going to fix my back.
Like that's not where they started.
Right?
Well and that's a problem,
right?
I mean to back problems are fucking
horrible.
I mean that is a part of the problem is
people get desperate.
They do not know what to do.
Just like when you were saying you were
getting those horrible headaches and
you're like,
I'll fucking try anything.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to go GMO
free.
I'm going to drink water only.
I'm going to.
Yeah.
I gave up my beloved Diet Coke Dark
Times.
You get worried,
you get worried and you start thinking
about different ways that you can.
And then if someone comes along and
says,
look,
this is the solution.
Just stick with it.
I need to see you twice a week.
This one guy that I was going to,
it was like,
you got to come more often,
buddy.
That's really the way I go.
I've got to get you to move my neck more
often.
The fuck are you doing really?
You know?
And I stopped going to him.
I was going to this one guy and he had a
really good massage therapist and I was
getting a massage therapy.
Then I stopped getting the chiropractic
adjustment and then he was like,
look,
you gotta you gotta get the chiropractic
adjustment too,
and I was like,
I'm kidding.
One thing is helping me.
The other thing,
I don't feel anything.
I just.
It sounds cool.
I like the sound was like pop,
pop that crick feels cool.
It feels good.
Like when you do this,
that feels good,
but that's the same fucking thing that a
chiropractor is doing to you.
But then they tell you not supposed to
do that to your fingers.
I'm like,
well,
why?
Well,
it can cause arthritis.
Oh,
how the fuck do you know how many I've
been doing it my whole life.
I don't have arthritis.
Well,
the question is kind of like we're
talking about with longterm pesticide
exposure.
I don't know where that's gonna land me
when I'm 70.
I believe it.
That causes arthritis 70.
They're just going to throw some new
touareg at me and it will be fine.
Point was that you can't have it both
ways.
If this causes arthritis,
how the fuck are you allowed to crack my
neck all the time?
That's an excellent points.
Like,
well,
it's one or the other.
It's funny.
I've had um,
one person.
It's funny for all the people who
messaged me because you asked what the
feedback was.
It wasn't just,
you know,
chiropractors who would really mad.
I had some people say my parents brought
me for Chiropractic when I was a kid and
now my back is fucked up.
So I mean,
and I don't know how many stories there
are like that from people saying,
you know,
we started chiropractic when I was a
baby and this was not the way to go for
me,
but God,
some of the responses to the article be
Jesus fucking Christ.
Well,
what does that woman who just died,
the playboy model or assuming the
chiropractor there are like the sudden
very,
you know,
kind of violent,
a way that they crack a neck and
chiropractic can leave you open to,
to severing an artery in your neck.
Now it's not often that it happens,
but it happens and this is one of those
things that I have a really big
contention with chiropractic with is
that they have all these mornings about
how western medicine and it's kind of
funny that they call it Western medicine
when chiropractic started in the middle
of the,
of the US.
Um,
it's like you don't get to claim that
you made this in China for fuck sakes,
but like they'll,
they'll say that western medicine is so
horrible for you and it has all these
potential side effects and yeah,
it has potential side effects,
but they have potential side effects
while they actually cure shit.
You have potential side effects while
you're cracking someone's neck.
Like the potential side effects too.
You're talking about 320 million people
that are going to the doctor.
If you have 100,000 cases of potential
side effects across the board from all
causes,
that's what they're harping on her
harping on the minority of things that
happen
and go wrong.
And then,
you know,
obviously there's some shit like
thalidomide and some stuff that people
don't use anymore that are horrible.
And the side effects,
what am.
I never made it to the US.
That's something a lot of people don't
realize really.
It was used in other countries,
other countries.
Now we had one regulator in the US who
saw the drug was coming up for approval
here and she said,
no,
we have to look into this more.
And then they saw the cases in Europe,
uh,
of all these infants that were being
born with major side effects.
And she was like,
Ah,
told Ya.
So that was,
that was how they started.
And this was what,
this is actually what gave us a,
one of the best,
uh,
acts for regulation,
for safety and efficacy in the u.
s and basically it said that drugs
before they make it to market now have
to be proven beyond a certain amount to
show that they are both safe and
effective.
And it was basically thalidomide that
launched that,
uh,
that act,
which is,
which is kind of like we're good at
learning from our mistakes.
Uh,
in,
in far I say we,
like,
I work for it,
but no,
it's like,
you know,
we're good at learning from our mistakes
when we have a fuck up like that.
So I mean,
I don't know what and what worries me is
that we're going to have eventually
another way we can very easily have
another drug like that,
but it will be something that we haven't
regulated out of the system yet.
So I don't know what the next thing will
be,
but it'll be something that we haven't
seen yet.
So that's the,
that that's the kind of a scary thing.
It'll be,
it'll be like we already know to test
for things in utero.
We already noticed the tests for things
that uh,
you know,
that can cause cancer.
We already know certain types of testing
a like,
but the little mermaid,
it was so crazy nontoxic.
They couldn't get it to kill a rat.
How nutty is that?
It was pretty crazy.
When did the babies?
Uh,
yeah,
I mean it's,
it's crazy that something that was,
that was the purpose of it.
It was,
it was used for a lot of different
things and the thing that they gave it
to mothers for was to stop a morning
sickness that would still used in a few
treatments,
just don't get it anywhere near a
pregnant woman.
So the,
they gave it,
it was really,
really good for learning or phrase it,
it was really effective at stopping
morning sickness,
but just nobody had a clue that it was
what it was causing to,
you know,
in Utero,
um,
and it was causing limbs to not be
formed and it was causing all these
crazy things and tens of thousands of
babies were born deformed before they
went.
Yikes.
Pull the plug.
Isn't there also an issue with approving
drugs isn't,
isn't there an also an issue with
biodiversity and that like,
you have issues that I don't have.
And so there's,
there's gonna be things that affect you
that are not going to affect me and vice
verse.
And this is why after,
and this is,
uh,
an interesting that happens.
So it's,
you know,
as you,
uh,
happened with,
with your neurotrauma nootropics.
Nootropics.
Okay.
Sorry,
my apologies.
So a,
um,
so with a w so you know about a phase
three clinical trials and all that from,
from that,
um,
so when you get to phase three,
generally you're testing between three
and 10,000 people in the population and
you've gotten through a few trials,
you know,
that this effective for this,
you want to see if people have you're
testing for allergic reactions in your
testing to see where people are going to
have issues with the drug so that when
you get to market,
you know that,
you know,
these people,
like this is the percentage of people
that have these side effects as a
percentage with these.
If you have these side effects,
call your doctor right away.
Just continued that type of stuff.
But that's three to 10,000 people.
You don't know who you're going to give
it to.
That's on x medication that has x
disorder on top of the thing you're
treating for that type of stuff.
Um,
or if it could cause someone to die,
these things can happen.
And like,
that's kind of what happened with Vioxx
is that,
you know,
they didn't,
they,
there were some people in that room who
probably strokes and some folks it was
arthritis medication and it was like he
got a stroke from that part.
Oh Wow.
Holy Shit.
And I mean,
there were,
there were people in that room who
probably look at it and said,
all right,
so there's this risk factor,
uh,
that's,
that causes you to increase your
possible risk factor by x percent.
What if somebody has all of these risk
factors combined?
Uh,
and you know,
like,
well you shouldn't approve it because
there's a chance if you put it on
somebody on this who has all of these
combined,
it's,
there's a chance that they're gonna have
their chances of getting a stroke is or
you know,
having an issue with their heart.
What is it harder tech firm it is going
to be through the roof.
We shouldn't approve it.
And it got approved anyway.
And it's one of those drugs that
shouldn't have been put through a lot of
was heart attacks,
stroke from it.
Oh,
it's a blood clot.
That must have been blood clots,
but yeah,
it's like it's just been significant
issues with some folks.
Yeah,
and it's like there is a chance when you
put any drug through now they try to get
through things to minimize this,
but because a phase three trial only
test in,
you know,
a certain amount of the population,
they try to get a diverse group when you
get it out,
you don't know what the possible effects
are going to be on someone else.
So you might see new side effects
depending on the other drugs someone is
onto because you know,
you're not prescribing these to healthy
people,
you're prescribing this to a sick
person.
So yeah,
that,
that definitely can happen.
So that's my first certain amount of
time after drugs on the market.
They do post a lot is kind of phase four
clinical trials.
You're doing a postmarket monitoring,
so that does go on for a certain amount
of time and sometimes drugs are pulled
based on the amount of side effects.
The other things,
and that doesn't happen often,
but it can happen based upon,
you know,
the amount of issues that you see after
it hits market.
What are your thoughts about advertising
drugs on television?
Like a ask your doctor about this,
your doctor.
It's,
I have,
I would say mixed feelings,
but most of my feelings are that it's a
bad thing.
Um,
and it's the only good thing I see from
it and I mean most of my feelings about
are still,
if it's a bad idea,
the only good thing I see about it is
that if you have a,
um,
a,
a patient that's got a shitty disease to
work with,
they get aware that there's a new
medication to treat it,
but you know,
where they should be getting that
information there.
Dr. Exactly.
So ask your doctor,
maybe maybe you know what your doctor
is,
if you're asking them a drug dealer.
Well,
the problem is when they show these
people holding hands and spinning around
in a field of wheat and having the
greatest time in their life and
butterflies are flying around and
puppies are magnetically drawn to them.
Enough drugs for that.
So that's the problem is like they have
beautiful music playing there are
manipulating you.
Like and it's,
I,
I don't,
I don't feel like that's like,
no,
it's not appropriate.
I lived in England for a year and when I
was over there I realized I'm like,
I'm like,
where were all the drug advertisements?
Like this is not a thing out here.
It's an amazing.
It's free,
it's different.
It was,
it was.
There are some things that were kind of
crazy about that.
I like,
I landed in the hospital overnight once
when I was there and I was so like,
I know you already knew that I had no
copays.
When I went to a doctor,
I'm like,
I'm in the hospital overnight.
Fuck fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
I'm to like,
this is going to cost me 10 grand.
When I left they were like,
did you take a cab here?
I'm like,
no,
why?
They're like,
Oh,
if you had,
we were going to pay for it.
I'm like,
what,
who are you people?
This is why I'm an American.
I don't know what to do with myself.
I'm just going to give us the treatment,
the treatment rate.
Is it the same over there?
Because I,
I have friends in Canada and they have
massive complaints about the medical
system in terms of like,
if you get injured,
it takes a long time.
All my relatives are,
I have like five relatives in this
country.
The rest all live in Nova Scotia and
there are,
I'd say it's a mixed bag.
So if you need urgent care or regular
care,
like you need to go to the doctor for a
checkup,
you need your,
you know,
the annuals,
um,
or you have a fucking heart attack.
You,
I would say you're better off living in
Canada.
Um,
I had a little cousin that was born with
basically no chambers in her heart,
which is horrifying.
Uh,
you know,
it's like they saw it in Utero,
um,
and it was like,
okay,
we're going to have to give this child
and operation like almost immediately
when she was born for the next two years
out of surgery,
almost every like open heart surgery
every year on the dot of a year as the
heart grows.
And it was like we asked,
you know why?
Yeah,
it was,
I mean they couldn't do all the fixing
because they needed to do it as a heart
got bigger.
And what do they do?
How do they do that?
And I mean,
I,
I wish I knew all the technicalities,
but you'd have to talk to a heart
surgeon chamber.
So would the heart look like?
I'm not exactly sure.
I never saw the pictures of it,
but I mean it's a,
I'll,
I'll hunt down my,
uh,
her father,
my cousins,
a blog that documented it if you want to
have a peak.
But it was a fairly rare condition of
the heart was I believe when she was
born,
like I was a little closer to the center
of the chest.
Like it's a,
it was a very,
like my mom said that when she held her,
when she was first born,
like the pulsing even felt sounded a
little different than a normal infant's
heart like it was,
but I mean the first,
at first they did a surgery that kind of
put a band around the heart,
a to give it a little more structure and
then they formed more chambers and then
when she was three,
they put in like full chambers.
Now she,
the only thing she can't do is she can't
play contact sports and they paid
nothing.
She can't play contact sports because of
possibility of causing,
um,
I'm not sure exactly what it can do,
but it's,
you know,
there's,
it can cause a little bit too much
trauma to a heart that's already been
through a lot of trauma.
But that's the only thing that she's
been told not to do.
Don't kick box.
Yeah.
No kickboxing,
no good.
No good.
She can run,
she can.
I believe she can run,
She's happy.
Active little kid.
Looks really healthy.
Uh,
is about the same.
she's,
she's a twin and she's got,
she's about the same height as her
brother,
like she's a,
why didn't they just take her to a
chiropractor where they could adjust to
see if you'd been there to suggest this
show.
She'd be fine.
Rub the back of your.
I went from maybe she never known what a
pal throw stickers.
One of them things that credit card,
just put it under a feet once you sleep,
but some energy for her food.
I went to this one motherfucker who is
treating a bunch of fighters and he was
a zone healer.
Do you know what a zone healers heard of
it?
But I'm excited now.
Seem like such a nice guy.
He was a chiropractor too,
he seemed like,
and it probably is a nice guy,
but he would press the back of your head
or like little spots and he's like,
does this hurt here?
Does this hurt here,
And then you press harder.
And I go,
well that one's Kinda S.
and he's like,
well there could be an issue with the
hypothalamus or some shit like that.
I was like,
what?
And so you know,
I'm a pretty skeptical per.
I've been hoodwinked before,
but I'm pretty skeptical and when I know
that someone's pushing on a part of my
head harder,
asking me if that part,
then claiming that they can tell from
the fucking skin on the cover on your
skull,
this is the skin on your skull.
Like they can tell like did this is the
area,
this is all,
you've got an issue with your liver,
the liver area.
When I squeezed on pressure on it,
so it's like,
no,
this is the liver right there,
so me and this guy get into it and so I,
I go,
I mean I'm being respectful,
but I'm like,
what are you doing?
And he's like,
well this is called zone healing.
He's explaining this zone healing thing
to me and I'm like,
what did you do?
And I'm like,
well it can cure all these different
diseases.
Don't talk to me about all these
different autoimmune diseases that it
can cure and all these different things.
I go,
well,
how's it working?
It's like,
well,
it's just the way that I'm manipulating
you in a certain way and the with the
frequencies and what.
So I'm like,
come on man,
how the fuck is this working?
I'm like,
that doesn't make any sense.
And so then we get to it and he's like,
you understand the placebo effect,
right?
And I go,
yeah,
well the placebo effect is you give
someone a sugar pill,
you tell them what's medicine and
somehow or it magically heels from Ryan.
He's like,
yeah.
And he's like,
well,
this is essentially what we do.
And I go,
so you're bullshitting and you're
letting these people's bodies heal
themselves.
He goes,
I wouldn't put it that way.
I,
of course you wouldn't put it that way
because you're charging money for this.
Like,
Lisa,
you're saying that what you're doing
doesn't really do anything.
He goes,
but it does.
I go,
it does.
He goes,
if you believe in it,
it does.
Jesus fucking have to believe
in penicillin.
Okay.
Exactly.
But that's.
It was so disturbing to me because I
knew a bunch of guys who had gone to
them and they're like,
oh,
this guy is fixing my knee,
and I was like,
what?
He's fixing your knee by adjusting your
neck.
He's fixing your knee.
He's not fixing your knee.
Your knee is getting healed because
you're taking time off.
I just want to heal.
You know,
the body knows how to heal.
I want to reflexologist mechanic for my
car.
I want someone to start reflexologist.
Same thing as where they were.
They.
They say that it's not just that they're
messing with your feet there.
They're giving a reflexology massage
where they tap on certain parts of your
feet and they say it's healing her
liver,
so give me a reflexologist mechanic so
that they're tapping on my tires and
it's like,
no,
no.
I'm working on your radiator.
I want to see that.
Yeah.
I'm not aware of reflexology.
I've seen those places where they show
like a chart of the feet and it looks.
Might as well be a fucking palm reader.
Right?
You're walking by and they have a one of
those neon signs and so they.
What do they do?
They say that by tapping on certain,
like this part the arch is really your
liver and your toes are really.
Your arch is your liver or I'm not sure.
I like,
I'm but like that's the same shit.
Oh yeah.
But like I said,
give me,
give me like the Chiropractic,
a reflexologist of,
of the mechanic world.
I want them to start tapping on,
on my oil tank and say,
Oh really?
I'm fixing your alternator.
Like none of nobody does this shit for
cars because you know why your car won't
run.
There's a real problem with people
saying they know things that they don't
really know and I think people get
really upset by it and I think it's one
of the reasons why it's so important to
be honest about what you actually know
and when you don't actually know.
You know.
I think that's.
That to me is like the most important
currency.
Like you should never give up how you
honestly feel and what you honestly
think and what you honestly know about.
Something and as soon as,
so as soon as you are a fucking
astrologer or a card reader or a palm
reader or a psychic,
you're a bullshit artist.
This is you,
you,
you're.
The reason you exist is because we can't
really read minds because if I could
know that you don't really know that if
I could see a little Turkey tests or pop
up on your head,
well I know you're full of shit.
Like,
Oh,
you're fucking tester popped up,
homie.
Oh yeah.
It's like the way you.
I think if anyone out there,
because I'm guessing your audience
doesn't have a lot of people who believe
in psychics,
but if anyone should,
they do.
If anyone out there truly believes in a
psychic walk into one and when they ask
you your name,
just walk right the fuck back out.
Because if they were a real psychic,
they would know you were coming and they
would know your name.
Yeah.
Maybe they weren't paying attention.
They to check.
See if you're lying.
If you say,
my name is Fred,
like,
okay,
mark,
so just walk right in.
Walk right in and give them a false
story and see if they check it.
I have a friend who went to a psychic
and he was like,
dude,
this guy knew all about my grandma.
I'm like,
don't you know about your grandma?
Fuck,
are you talking about man?
She was.
She was an old lady and she was grandma
like.
And she coached things that you like.
See,
I know about your grandma too.
Motherfucker
will they give you,
they give you these leading questions
and then you give them information.
They're really good at reading.
Banner check is.
Oh yeah.
I'm friends with the
Penn and teller.
I love those guys there.
It's,
it's funny guys.
I learned a lot of my writing style kind
of from that and there was,
it was funny,
there was a night a backstage after the
show once where I was talking about like
what I was doing with,
uh,
with the writing with teller.
And one of the things he said it was
about getting the script back for the
chiropractic episode and they have to be
really careful with how they wrote the
episodes of bullshit bullshit.
Oh yeah,
great show.
And it was funny because like I,
I turned into a skeptic from watching
that show and it was just great because
like,
I,
you know,
obviously I'd never heard her talk
before I got to know that group and it
was like that was,
that was the first time because I Chit
chatted with,
tell her a little bit before because I
got to know penn first and hearing
teller describe,
like after I started doing the sybase
thing,
I'm chatting with him about that.
I got a little insight into his brain.
He's like,
yeah,
we got the script back from legal and
they said just call the chiropractor's
motherfuckers.
I'm like,
inside.
I gotta keep my composition,
but my lord,
that was like hearing teller say mother
fuckers.
Oh,
that sounds like something penn would
say takes these motherfuckers.
It's,
there's basically everything you hear in
pens,
tone of voice.
You have to hear it in this tone of
voice.
Like I've learned a lot about.
I've learned a lot about skeptic being
responsibly from him.
And one of the things I've always taken
away is don't blame the victim.
Uh,
and that's,
that's something that I've kept with me
and I'll always keep with me.
It's,
he's a,
he's been a big influence on my work and
it's been,
it's been helpful.
Yeah,
I mean we've all been hoodwinked,
mean at some stage of your life,
whether it's your parents telling you
about Santa Claus or something along the
way.
We've been tricked and it's not your
fault that you got tricked the prop man.
Sometimes it's not even the fault of the
person's tricking if they're being
sincere and they're just,
they're just misinformed and they don't
understand what they're doing is
actually harmful.
And then they fight for their cause.
Like they have this thing that they do,
whether it's chiropractic or whether
it's being an astrologer or whatever.
Then they like,
they dig in and they defend their turf
yet.
But I,
I apologize for interrupting or saying
about band check.
It's or if you were about to go into
when they fold people at their fake
site,
put the fake psychic.
No,
I'm good.
He is at reading people and we had him
on.
I did a show called Joe Rogan questions
everything.
And Bennett check was one of the
episodes where he was explaining to me
how they do cold read and explained to
me how they lead people into giving him
enough information that he can form a
reasonable assessment of who they are.
And then he would answer certain,
asked certain leading questions and he's
like,
I've just done this so many times,
I know how to get the.
And people are shocked and they don't
know what to do and they've never done
this before.
So,
you know,
it's like you can ask them questions and
they start giving you information and
like your parents were divorced when you
were young.
How do you know?
Because it's,
it's so common,
first of all,
and you know,
you can read certain things from people.
And I mean,
he showed us a bunch of shit that he
does,
like the spoon bending thing,
a bunch of different things that people
want you to say that it's magic.
It's funny because there's a big
crossover with the magician community,
uh,
and the skeptic community.
And it's because they know how easy it
is to trick the fuck out of people.
And I kind of love that.
It's kind of,
it's been interesting to see this group
of entertainers that people think of as
goofballs be this kind of a little bit
of a bastion of intellectual ism.
Because I,
I like it.
It's hard to get people to pay attention
to anything on the Internet.
But if you make it funny and you add a
Dick joke,
suddenly people are like,
I got to learn about this.
So that's why Penn and teller think are
so important.
Because they were the first magicians
who were really adamant and what they're
doing is bullshit.
Like,
nope,
we're tricking you.
And they use that word trick.
And I liked that they were really good
at.
It's still going to be awesome.
You're still going to watch.
And every grade time.
And they were,
they were totally upfront.
They're like,
no,
there's no magic.
We're motherfucking tricking you.
There's shows.
God Damn.
Those shows were hilarious.
Some of those bullshit shows with a
catch people.
And this,
the,
the nonsense that they're promoting
pushing.
One of my favorite ones is there was a,
uh,
there was an episode where they attacked
organic food and they did,
and this is this thing where people
doubled down on things.
Uh,
they took a banana,
cut it in half,
and it was,
I believe a conventionally grown banana.
And on one plate they'd say it was an
organic banana.
The other plate,
they'd say it was a organic,
the other plate a conventionally grown
and have people take a bite out of each
one and people,
you know,
they'd sit there describing the organic
banana is creamy and sweet and tastes
like a banana.
Should taste.
And the conventionally grown.
Yeah,
it's really bland and it doesn't taste
good.
And this one girl,
after they explained to quote pen,
it's the same fucking but m and this one
girl afterwards,
she's like,
I don't know if it makes me question my,
my opinion of organic versus
conventional.
It really makes me question the concept
of the banana.
I'm like,
oh girl,
you're going to waste so much money.
It's pulled it off.
I got mad at me yesterday.
I did.
The dumb girl wants.
Well it's,
I,
it's,
it's a skill.
It's one of the skills I bring to the
table.
We can get away with it though.
It's girls can get away with it.
I'd say.
I,
I think I thought I got an okay
impression of Penn,
but no yelling,
no it just enough attempting to destroy
my vocal cords will,
will produce a pen impression almost
what I think it's a unique time for
exposing bullshit and you know,
because there's enough articles and
videos and there's enough.
Like you can kind of get a sense like,
oh I see a pattern here.
People are a lot of people.
I think people are tired of not knowing
what's real on the Internet and it's
partially like this whole trend with
fake news and like,
there,
there's kind of a breaking point I think
in terms of what people
are,
are willing to accept a for just shit
being spewed on the Internet and being
accepted as real because there's so much
content out there and people want to
spend their time reading stuff that's
for real and that they can trust and
they don't want to trust shitty sources,
you know,
like they want to go,
all right,
here's a source I can trust,
I can keep going back to this website.
I can get good information.
And they want things explained,
uh,
that they know was researched well.
And I,
I think that this is a,
this is a valuable good to offer out to
people saying,
you know,
here's something real and here's some.
And here's a Dick joke to read while
you're reading something real.
So I am for a good Dick joke to,
to research ratio
for as well.
Now when you did this article and you
know,
you said it was 4,000 words,
it's a particularly long article.
What did you have to omit?
I mean,
did it seems like,
when you're dealing with 4,000 words,
I mean it,
was it just the,
the comprehensive coverage on why
chiropractic websites bullshit?
Or is it just like,
like,
God damn,
I gotTa keep this thing as tight as I
can,
but there's so much to.
Well,
it's,
I was going to joke while I do get paid
by the word.
Well that's true,
but it wasn't like I never go into it
going,
let's make it as long as I can or make
it as short as I can.
We like I'm a contributing writer at the
outline now.
Um,
and this is,
and it's whenever we write a piece,
it's always,
let's make it cover the topic in as
entertaining and,
and as,
uh,
as cohesive as a,
of a story as possible.
I'm old.
Go for it.
Let's go.
We kind of say what points do we want to
cover in this piece?
And sometimes it's um,
and it's basically to tell a good story.
And My,
my goal whenever I write an article in
something is let's write the best,
uh,
let's write a piece so that I never have
to cover this topic again.
And with Chiropractic,
like I like,
I could.
One thing I would have liked to have
covered if somehow we could have made it
like either,
you know,
if,
if somehow we could have condensed it a
little so we could have fit something
else in,
I would have maybe added an a piece on
our,
they're science,
science-based chiropractors.
Is that possible?
Here's an impossible to be a science
based card reader.
Yeah.
I mean that's the problem is like,
I feel like,
like it was,
we tried to present one point of view
while still giving a hat too.
Like we included a link on some
chiropractors that are showing,
you know,
that they're trying to be science based.
So I think that adding in a whole
section on it would have maybe
diminished from the point of view of it.
So being,
making it good reading and you know,
a cohesive point of view is always
important to the article.
Right.
But let me stop you there.
You say chiropractor science based.
If it was bullshit when it started,
if it was something that was created by
a magnetic healer,
it was,
it was a nonsense thing that came from a
seance.
How does that ever become science based?
If the original,
the origin.
It's not based on medical research where
they figured out that if you do,
look,
here's all
the studies that we've shown when you do
this,
this is the immune system responds to
the body has to be in.
There's none of that,
right?
It doesn't exist.
Well there is,
there is some and it some but the minor
evidence but subjective pain relief and
that's it and I don't want to diminish
and this is something that I'm sure
people are sitting there like with
daggers still mad at us for saying,
you know,
for questioning their,
their subjective experiences.
I don't want to tell people that they
did not feel relief from what they cause
pain is.
It's really subjective and it's hard to
manage.
So I think that there are chiropractors
who aim specifically to relieve lower
back pain.
Um,
and I mean,
I think if you aim just to do that,
uh,
with your chiropractic practice while
still telling people,
look,
I'm just doing this while you go to
physical therapy,
you should still be going to a physical
therapist.
This is an adjunctive things solely to
relieve pain and they try to see how it
can just relieve pain.
I think it's possible that,
that can do that,
but I think that adding that into the
article,
it takes away from it a bit,
uh,
because that's,
that's not part of the article's point
of view.
And it's also not part of my point of
view of how it's not a science based
practice.
So I think that,
and I mean,
I've seen some ethical chiropractors,
there's Sam Homo,
Pamela.
I'm not sure how to pronounce his name.
I've never heard it said out loud
before.
Uh,
but that was one of the chiropractors
who I cited in there who,
you know,
he's continued to practice while
speaking out against the Chiropractic,
very vocally speaking out against
Chiropractic as a whole because he's
seen that it can,
you know,
and there is some adult manipulating
back he is,
but he's what's going on there,
what does that do?
And that's what all the things where I
feel like I'm in a gray area because I
don't want to diminish the people who've
said that it's helped them have pain
relief.
But I also think these people should be
going to,
um,
you know,
to a,
uh,
you know,
to a physical therapist and a massage
therapist.
So I'm not sure what the,
I'm not sure what the exact right answer
is on that.
If someone says,
I've been to a physical therapist,
I've been to a massage therapist and
this is the only thing that's ever made
it feel better.
And I went in one session,
what do you say?
Like,
and I don't know where the exact right
answer is to that,
but if it all started from bullshit,
it seems so hard.
If the foundation is bullshit.
Yeah,
and I mean I went to a guy that was
really good at a bunch of other stuff,
like he would give you a dms electrical
muscular pads on.
I have one,
I have a small little car.
He had really good massage therapist who
provided physical therapy.
He had a little gym set up at the end of
the day.
Still cracking backs.
Well,
here's a question.
What if,
and this is again at this completely
hypothetical,
what if it hadn't been started by this
nutjob back into killer and it was a
doctor who said,
oh,
this can,
this can help.
And if it was a just an osteopath who
was trying to see if this could help
relieve pain along with physical
therapy.
So I,
I encourage people if they're,
if they are looking for a way that
manipulation can help,
maybe not go to a chiropractor,
but seek out in your medical practice
and osteopath who can,
who knows much more about anatomy and
please keep going to a physical
therapist and maybe a massage therapist
because ms dot.
I just feel fucking great.
So that's just,
it's so hard to say that,
you know,
there's like science based ones when it
all started out with bullshit,
like,
you know,
it's going to be,
it will be very hard for you to find a,
you know,
quote unquote science based
Chiropractor,
please,
if you're,
you know,
if the only thing that's relieving your
back pain and I get it,
I have,
you know,
I have scoliosis back pain issues are
very hard to manage a,
you know,
an osteopath will understand your
anatomy much better.
They're not going to say you have to
come back in three times a week,
they're going to send you to a physical
therapist and you know,
maybe recommended massage,
but they'll,
they'll do it in a,
in an ethical fashion.
Uh,
and not overstep their reached.
But that's,
you know,
there is some evidence that it helps
with lower back pain but not more than
physical therapy or massage.
And that's,
I think what people should take away
from this.
I'm not saying it can't do anything,
I'm saying it's not the best thing.
And that's also a problem because most
chiropractors also incorporate massage
and it's so hard to decide like what,
what is helping you?
Yeah.
And I mean that's like,
I think it's,
and I get it like I'm a,
I don't want to.
I think the hardest part is telling
people that their subjective experiences
wrong because that's like,
you don't,
I don't want to be that asshole who's
like necessarily you're saying it's
wrong,
but you're saying reevaluate what the
root cause.
Yeah.
And it's like,
I know what I mean.
It's like if you went to a chiropractor,
you're not stupid.
You're not wrong.
You're not a moron.
You're,
you know,
you're someone who's suffering.
And I both have both of us understand
that it's just,
you know,
make sure you're not being,
that the person who's selling to you
isn't selling a line and not telling you
that it can fix your immune system and
cure your baby to the point where it
doesn't need to.
Please,
please don't let someone do that to you
because measles,
measles is a real thing that can.
I was hoping cough.
It's Ian.
This is kind of,
uh,
have,
did you,
uh,
it's,
um,
have you ever gotten a whooping cough?
Because once I got it,
I got it as an adults because in this is
kind of,
this is kind of shitty.
They do need to make a new whooping
cough vaccine that is not a reason not
to get it.
Please get it,
please re up it.
But the whooping cough vaccine,
when they made it a,
some strains of it wore off faster,
uh,
than was originally expected.
Somebody came into my lab and we were,
I mean,
we were given,
um,
you know,
along with our packages working to labs
ago,
I'm at a drug testing lab.
Um,
we were given health insurance and it
was around the time of the first
obamacare debate,
you know,
when people are all like,
I don't need to buy healthcare.
And one of the guys in the lab who was
all,
why should I get healthcare?
I'm healthy.
He showed up with whooping cough and for
two weeks we didn't know he had it.
He was just sick.
And everyone's like,
Craig,
go to the doctor,
five of us got whooping cough from one
guy from one guy.
Let him hear the end of it.
Fucking Craig.
It's fucking Craig,
man.
Fucking Craig.
Um,
I,
uh,
I was out of work.
We all had to stay out of work for five
days.
All of us who had it.
So.
And I'm like.
And within the course of a month,
and this was just bad luck within the
course of a month,
I had had hip surgery,
a torn ligament in my hip running an
ultra marathon.
Never,
uh,
don't,
don't run an ultra marathon.
It's a bad idea.
Was hitting a car accident and got
whooping cough with it.
Wait,
that was six weeks.
So I'm like,
I had no vacation time left to miss
work.
And I was out because somebody coughed
on me.
Buddy of mine runs ultra marathons all
the time there.
I didn't realize at the time that I had
a joint disorder.
Yeah.
Well don't run them a few of a buildup
to him.
Oh No.
You need to try.
And I mean I trained properly,
it just,
I didn't realize I'm like,
my hip is hurting and I went to my
surgeon and this is,
this is something that I,
that chiropractic does a yell about in
the pain care system and in,
in the medical system that they have a
point about Dr Stu throw pills at you
haphazardly.
My doctor and I'm,
I'm never gonna not be mad about this.
My doctor,
instead of saying we should do a scan
with contrast to see what's going on
because you're really complaining about
this.
Chucked me a bottle of Vicodin and said
go ahead and run.
Yeah.
Doctor's name.
Oh yeah.
I'm not going to say because you know,
it's like it's,
there was that part of me that was
really happy that I got to do my ultra.
But God damn it,
if you need Vicodin to run a marathon,
don't do it.
Dr. Oh yeah.
It's.
I mean don't,
don't do that.
But I mean it was funny because after I
ran it,
I'm like,
alright,
I don't need to take the medication any
more because I'm not running.
And suddenly I realized how fucked up my
hip was and it was like,
oh my God,
I can barely walk.
Like,
what was wrong with him?
He tore a ligament or a torn my labor.
Um,
and it was like it was tightened up.
Just say it's,
I mean,
there's all they have are like two
little scars because like,
it was,
it was such an easy surgery that the day
of surgery it felt less bad than it did
the day before.
Um,
and it was like,
it was fun.
It was the week that I turned 29.
I'm like,
it's turned into an and already I'm
getting hip surgery.
I'm like,
this was,
uh,
yeah.
So that was my,
my,
all of my surgeries have been on.
I'm pretty sure my parents dropped me as
a baby and just won't admit to it
because my headache left side three
surgeries on my left shoulder surgery on
my left hip.
I'm like,
I'm right handed,
but I'm doing everything with your right
side.
Left,
left side's atrophy kind of
ambidextrous.
One of my friends is an archery
instructor and I'm learning how to to
shoot bows and arrows,
you know,
just just in case the revolution come.
No,
not really,
but it's,
I'm,
I'm off.
I shoot with a,
my hand,
my strong hand is my left hand and I'm
like my dominant on my left.
I pulled back on the wait,
which one gets back on the left and the
left and pull back on the left and my
right arm keeps getting bruised like
crazy and I have to keep explaining to
people that I'm not getting hit the skin
slapping with this one need better form.
Yeah,
and it keeps on going up.
Why don't you put one of those risk
things?
Are they the forum thing?
Have one and it's the worst.
This is the worst thing that happens
because like all I have to do is go like
this to get my arm out of the way and
instead the couple of this is the worst
is when the string catches right here
and this giant bruise.
Right?
Using a compound bow or a traditional
bow.
I think it's along,
but I don't know off the top of the cams
in it,
like these big.
No,
it's,
it's a,
it's a fairly simple starter bow.
It's my friend,
my friend Anna.
She's,
she knows all the things we're doing and
it's like,
I'm just kind of show from Mike,
Please let me not kill myself.
So it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a thing where it's like,
it's a lot of fun and I'm,
I,
I'm loving the crap out of it.
It's great.
A great workout,
especially for your lats and uh,
and your upper shoulders.
But it's like,
dear God,
I'm,
I'm still clueless at what I'm doing.
It's funny because like,
she's like,
she's won a few tournaments.
She knows what she's doing.
Uh,
I'd gone shooting with her a few times.
Then we went to,
my boyfriend came with us and like,
he's hitting bull's eyes right away.
I'm like,
how the,
are you fucking kidding me?
He just naturally great at it.
I'm like,
what?
But I'm like,
I,
I saw meditation.
Oh yeah.
It's just,
you're just,
you're sitting there going,
who?
Who Do I want to pretend?
Isn't the Tartan,
but it's like,
no,
not at all.
I'm not.
I'm not an angry person.
Like it's,
it's funny.
I put all my,
all of my rage goes into my writing and
like,
that's,
that's like all of the unlike anger
daddy issues all the time,
so I didn't like why didn't,
why didn't this work?
God,
it,
all the anger goes into the writing.
Like the archery is just meditative.
Like it's relaxing.
It's like you're out in an open field.
There's,
it's like,
it's a really nice little archery range
up in Glendale.
Oh yeah,
I know where that is.
Yeah.
I feel like it's one of those things
where when you're doing it a requires so
much focus kind of drains you of
distractions.
Yeah.
You're just,
you're funny.
Whenever.
Here's my nerdy moments.
Whenever we walked from the car to the
range,
I turn on a superhero soundtracks and
just walk out there.
I'm like,
I can feel like a hero soundtracks.
Like,
uh,
it's the soundtrack to deadpool while
we're walking out there.
And I'm like,
oh,
I can,
I can feel slightly like a bad ass for
five seconds.
Okay.
Before I go back to my life as a writer,
well thank you for your writing.
Thank you for writing that article on
chiropractors being bullshit.
I'm sorry.
Chiropractors who are listening to this
are fuming and angry.
They're going to hate me.
It's okay.
Well,
I mean,
everything you said is right though.
The real problem is what you did was you
expose something.
It's the one thing I.
and I keep waiting for this there,
you know,
there was the one article where somebody
called me a sith Lord and I'm like,
they and they gave it up because the
article was a chiropractor.
I don't remember.
I think it was somebody who had went to
one and they said only a sif deals in
absolutes.
I'm like,
I'm part of the rebellion.
But no,
they uh,
that's so stupid.
It's a nerd out I,
I am a nerd and I'm okay with.
I'm there too.
But that's a,
that's so like,
that's such a nerd out way to fucking
criticize someone.
It's
really calling me a sith Lord.
I have that on my twitter profile now.
I'm like,
legends sit,
Lord,
bring it on.
But it's,
I'm like,
you know,
what?
After all the insults that people have
thrown,
I found an article written about me,
wants to know,
so beautiful that I said that I was,
uh,
that,
that I was on.
I was a big Pharma Shell because I had
admitted to taking medication for my
headache.
I'm like,
at that,
I don't think I'm a shell.
I think I'm,
I'm a customer.
They have the relationship backwards.
You can't read everything,
but no,
it's,
I can't fight the internet.
Talk about everything that you're
reading.
You go crazy.
What's the correct pronunciation of your
name?
You've met Donald Trump.
Donald trump.
I'll say one more time.
[inaudible] mall.
Donald trump.
Don trump will really go nowhere near as
scary.
Here we go.
Alright.
Thank you so much for having me.
Pleasure.
See you guys and girls and a non binary
folk.